so
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
mj the boss yeah
yeah i see you mj that's the homie
that's one of the originals
salute to you of everything is doing
good in sunny california i'm just doing
uh conferences and shows with you good
to see you up in there
we got up in here let's do it let's do a
roll call right quick
all right we got stern at a novad what's
up what's going on
talk to me talk to me let me show make
sure my levels are good
a little rusty a little vacation flow i
got to get back into the mix
lydia madison what's going on what's
going on gerald mack the og what's going
on ghost fixture what's going on j1 rick
gaffney catching the show live okay it's
your first one okay let's go finally
that's what's up jay gaming you know
what i'm saying three four thrills right
yeah we're gonna talk about them i imax
what's going on hassan tyrell what's up
lord metroid i see you nintendo in the
building switch game what's going on
luis jimenez ready for the smoke three
four three okay he got opinions
aurora rope where is your man where is
your man aurora wolf talk to me
lydia
going on what's going on good to see
y'all good to be back it's been a minute
for me for the minute to solve
vacation you know i'm saying king two
birthdays and all that but you know the
lord's gotta recharge the lord's gotta
recharge your mental health is important
and we love giving our show but
sometimes we got to take a little step
back and recharge yourself we do that a
little bit more this year
we've been doing this a long time and we
talked about it but it feels good to be
back it feels good so yeah what's up
server okay okay
absolute salute so yeah we have a good
show just the laws the brethren the
family the core essence of what this is
we got some good topics we got some fun
i'm saying spoke to king earlier pulling
up
attic i got to find him i don't know
where he's at
oh hold on hold on that's what i meant
god wish you the rest of those happy
city upcoming week look for hopefully
john oh yeah yeah the wolf i remember
you okay yes yes we talked before
yeah what's going on
thank you for that thank you for that it
should be a good show solve is back good
to hear the super text read
in the
[Music]
we got a lot to talk about and catch up
with y'all so i will be back about to
see if i can go catch attic wherever yet
these dallas bars
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lord's podcast right now as we speak and
uh i guess i'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
look y'all messed up and turned me to an
animal and haters be swearing they real
but come to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah i'll be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being accountable and they say i'm
better than money because you can bank
on me being accountable i know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable i kill a
beat and they want to compare me to
freddie and jason i'd rather be hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all so dramatical i know
it's random but i am addicted to
flipping the sample and making
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
to be your dog thing very loyal but i
ain't gonna hold you i ain't here to boy
you ain't gotta say it i'm embarrassed
for you always been a nerd never been a
loser making voltron with a gang of
cougars and i'm going places better tell
the uber cause it's pretty hard to sleep
on freddy krueger
let's do that again
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lords podcast right now as we speak and
uh i guess i'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
look y'all messed up and turned me to an
animal and headless be swearing they
real but come to find out that they
really mechanical and yeah i'll be
eating these rappers but that's all a
part of me being accountable and they
say i'm better than money because you
can bank on me being accountable i know
a million rappers that don't want to be
on the song with me that's
understandable i kill a beat and they
wanna compare me to freddie and jason
i'd rather be hannibal they'd be like
why use a video game just be original
y'all so dramatical i know it's random
but i'm addicted to flipping the sample
and making it flammable
this is the yoga fire flame they think
it's arson up in the apartment they call
the department and i get the blame still
i'll be running collecting them reigns
you just a target when i'm in the range
i was the hardest starter regardless
of people
check my vocals all on twitter but i'm
anti-social love my city but i'm still
by coastal
[Music]
been a nerd never been a loser making
voltron with a gang of cougars and i'm
going places better tell her uber cause
it's pretty hard to sleep on freddy
krueger
let's do that again
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lords podcast right now as we speak and
uh
i guess i'm here to keep you entertained
until it's time to get this show started
so um
look y'all messed up and turned me to an
animal and headless be swearing they
real but come to find out that they
really mechanical and yeah i be eating
these rappers but that's all a part of
me being accountable and they say i'm
better than money because you can bank
on me being accountable i know a million
rappers that don't want to be on the
song with me that's understandable i
kill a beat and they want to compare me
to freddie and jason i'd rather be
hannibal they'd be like why use a video
game just be original y'all so
dramatical i know it's random but i am
addicted to flipping the sample and
making it flammable
this is their yoga fire flame they think
it's arson up in the apartment they call
the department and i get the blame still
i'll be running collecting them rings
you just a target when i'm in the range
i was the hardest to start regardless
back we were messaging people
check my vocals all on twitter but i'm
anti-social love my city but i'm still
by coastal
[Music]
look i guess you could say that i'm very
spoiled for them to be your dogs ain't
very loyal but i ain't gonna hold you i
ain't here to boy you you ain't gotta
say it i'm embarrassed for you always
been a nerd never been a loser making
voltron with a gang of cougars and i'm
going places better tell an uber cause
it's pretty hard to sleep on freddy
krueger
let's do that again
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lords podcast right now as we speak and
uh i guess i'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
look y'all messed up and turned me to an
animal and headless be swearing they
real but coming to find out that they
really mechanical and yeah i'll be
eating these rappers but that's all a
part of me being accountable and they
say i'm better than money because you
can bank on me being accountable i know
a million rappers that don't want to be
on a song with me that's understandable
i kill a beat and they want to compare
me to freddie and jason i'd rather be
hannibal they'd be like why use a video
game just be original y'all so
dramatical i know it's random but i am
addicted to flipping the sample and
making it flammable this
[Applause]
they call the department and i get the
blame still i'll be running collecting
them rings you just a target when i'm in
the range i was the hardest to start
regardless back when you was messaging
people
check my votes
[Music]
very loyal but i ain't gonna hold you i
ain't here to boy you you ain't gotta
say it i'm embarrassed for you always
been a nerd never been a loser making
voltron with a gang of cougars and i'm
going places better tell her uber cause
it's pretty hard to sleep on freddy
krueger
let's do that
again here you hear you man welcome to
the show if you would not mind go ahead
and uh find yourself a spot get
comfortable grab a snack do all that
good stuff that we need to do and um you
know we're about to get started i am
well it's not important who i am uh
what's important is that you are pulling
up to the iron lords podcast right now
as we speak and uh i guess i'm here to
keep you entertained until it's time to
get this show started so um
look y'all messed up and turned me to an
animal and haters be swearing they real
but come to find out that they're really
mechanical and yeah i'll be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being accountable and they say i'm
better than money because you can bank
on me being accountable i know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable i kill a
beat and they wanna compare me to
freddie and jason i'd rather be hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all so dramatical i know
it's random but i'm addicted to flipping
the sample and making it flammable this
is that
this is their yoga fire flame they think
it's arson up in the apartment they call
the department and i get the blame still
i'll be running collecting them rings
you just a target when i'm in the range
i was the hardest to start regardless
back we was messaging people
check my vocals all on twitter but i'm
anti-social love my city but i'm still
by coastal
[Music]
never been a loser making voltron with a
gang of cougars and i'm going places
better tell her uber cause it's pretty
hard to sleep on freddy krueger
let's do that again
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lords podcast right now as we speak and
uh i guess i'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
look y'all messed up and turned me to an
animal and haters be swearing they real
but come to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah i'll be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being accountable and they say i'm
better than money because you can bank
on me being accountable i know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable i kill a
beat and they want to compare me to
freddie and jason i'd rather be hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original
[Applause]
up in the apartment they call the
department and i get the blame still
i'll be running collecting them rings
you just a target when i'm in the range
i was the hardest to start regardless
back we was messaging people
check my vocals all on twitter but i'm
anti-social love my city but i'm still
by coastal
[Music]
i guess you could say that i'm very
spoiled for them to be your dog thing
very loyal but i ain't gonna hold you i
ain't here to boy you you ain't gotta
say it i'm embarrassed for you i always
been a nerd never been a loser making
voltron with a gang of cougars and i'm
going places better tell her uber cause
it's pretty hard to sleep on freddy
krueger
let's do that again
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lords podcast right now as we speak and
uh i guess i'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
turn me to an animal and haters be
swearing they real but come to find out
that they really mechanical and yeah i
be eating these rappers but that's all a
part of me being accountable and they
say i'm better than money because you
can bank on me being accountable i know
a million rappers that don't want to be
on a song with me that's understandable
i kill a beat and they want to compare
me to freddie and jason i'd rather be
hannibal they'd be like why use a video
game just be original y'all so
dramatical i know it's random but i'm
addicted to flipping the sample and
making it flammable this is
[Applause]
up in the apartment they call the
department and i get the blame still
i'll be running collecting them reigns
you just a target when i'm in the range
i was the hardest to start regardless
back when you was messaging people
check my votes
[Music]
very loyal but i ain't gonna hold you i
ain't here to boil you you ain't gotta
say it i'm embarrassed for you i've
always been a nerd never been a loser
making voltron with a gang of cougars
and i'm going places better tell her
uber cause it's pretty hard to sleep on
freddy krueger
let's do that again
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lords podcast right now as we speak and
uh i guess i'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
look y'all to messed up and turned me to
an animal and haters be swearing they
real but come to find out that they
really mechanical and yeah i be eating
these rappers but that's all a part of
me being accountable and they say i'm
better than money because you can bank
on me being accountable i know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable i kill a
beat and they want to compare me to
freddie and jason i'd rather be hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all so dramatical i know
it's random but i am addicted to
flipping the sample and making it
flammable
this is their yoga fire flame they think
it's arson up in the apartment they call
the department and i get the blame still
i'll be running collecting them reigns
you just a target when i'm in the range
i was the hardest to start regardless
back when you was messaging people
check my vocals all on twitter but i'm
anti-social love my city but i'm still
by coastal
[Music]
never been a loser making voltron with a
gang of cougars and i'm going places
better tell her uber cause it's pretty
hard to sleep on freddy krueger
let's do that again
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lords podcast right now as we speak and
uh i guess i'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
look y'all messed up and turned me to an
animal and haters be swearing they real
but come to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah i be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being accountable and they say i'm
better than money because you can bank
on me being accountable i know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable i kill a
beat and they want to compare me to
freddie and jason i'd rather be hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all so dramatical i know
it's random but i'm addicted to flipping
the sample and making it flammable this
is that
this is their yoga fire flame they think
it's arcing up in the apartment they
call the department and i get the blame
still i'll be running collecting them
reigns you just a target when i'm in the
range i was the hardest to start
um
i guess you could say that i'm very
spoiled for them to be your dog thing
very loyal but i ain't gonna hold you i
ain't here to boy you you ain't gotta
say it i'm embarrassed for you i've
always been a nerd never been a loser
making voltron with a gang of cougars
and i'm going places better tell her
uber cause it's pretty hard to sleep on
freddy krueger
let's do that again
and we are
live
iron lord podcast
lord cognito here talking about the
latest with advanced gg there's a lot of
things going on with the new product
line let's get right to it
so we got that focus line y'all this is
that standard this is what we use right
now kind of our caffeine substitute and
what we usually do right now when we're
gaming we don't use coffee anymore we're
utilizing its focus on deck number two
you already know it's my favorite right
here the energy line you already know
birthday cake one of my absolute
favorites completely delicious this is a
pre-workout equivalent and also doesn't
use beta adeline so you don't get the
jitters and stuff like that so it's
really good for that and then the new
new we got that hydration line y'all
this is really good for people who don't
like caffeine who want an electrolyte
substitute and it is really sugar-free
absolutely delicious so you got your
three choices once again you know car
glove is sour you already know and we're
doing this right now so go get yourself
to advanced gg.com use code iron lord on
the checkout this is something i use all
the time gotta support advanced gg great
products if you want to get your workout
on even if you don't work out you're
just gaming you need that focus and
again the hydration line for those who
don't want caffeine no sugar
electrolytes you're good to go laura
cognito here iron law podcast peace
[Music]
a proclamation
[Music]
i'ma just chill and watch them any
snacks in the attic i wanted to chill
with the pack and be like a young wolf
but then they would mistake me for
addict if i can imagine it's cool to
give you some advice and invite your
girl to your squadron cause if you don't
give her that option you're gonna be
single player like siren you're gonna
get tossed in the bushes by king david
royalty and not a pretender detrimental
to an elemental what's an avatar to a
knee bender i gotta be me though i know
it's my destiny works incognito who
cares if you fly if you steal a mosquito
you swear you ain't something but really
be stevo
you like to collect stuff and that's
cool but i got bad news even if you
really was that jew king david still be
the king of the statues since the
juvenile i've been cursed with a curse
to be musical and if you hate it we'll
meet in the crucible wasn't it nothing
it's cool and it's beautiful we let you
know that your dreams are pursuable
whatever you want to do then it's doable
if you got work on a sunday it's
suitable cause you can listen to this in
your cubicle on the lord's day
if you got work on a sunday it's
suitable cause you can listen to this in
your cubicle on a lord's day
[Music]
while we figure it out
we laugh we laugh we think we lobby i
see levels i'll see let's talk to the
people real quick hello hello hello
hello hello how how's my levels how's my
level your levels are good sir oh it is
yo how's my beard though
oh he's back
yes all we got to do now is reboot the
crocs and you back up
[Applause]
and we got we got some you know they
advance gg crocs
[Laughter]
we were just talking last night about
how the fact that
we like king hit that
we had to comfortable like i don't even
see him happier
he's so happy right now
i thought i joined the nation to stop
[Laughter]
anyway
and we
are live
welcome back to the i always podcast llc
and also live on lorenzogaming.net
episode number 263 another glorious
sunday we are back at the round table on
the lord's date and today we got a
former bungee director joining 343
battlefield overtaking halo on steam
yeah read pop to run e3
got him xbox at gamescom and playstation
store movies to discuss so we gonna get
right into it so let's introduce the
returning the original the oh geez the
four horsemen of gaming the original
knights of the realm here at the round
table fresh off a two week to one week
vacation for some
my co-host with the co-votes my brother
from another mother the difficult game
conqueror lord of his own world and the
how of the young wolf my man trying to
get his camera together lord addict of
the attic show how we doing sir
doing pretty good one week vacation i
was here at 1pm last week
yes you were holding it down enjoy sir
what's up yeah you can't see the people
here yeah
the lady of royal ruff is like wait wait
i don't i don't know what's going on
with the camera yeah you got to figure
that out yeah i figured it out
yeah what it is you probably got another
source no it's not that you got to
recess
i mean this this might be stupid this
might be a stupid thing but make sure
the cap's not on it oh yo
you never know
you never know
this is just not turning on yeah suicide
said addict we can't see your bill
[Laughter]
anyway while you
uh i've been playing uh enchanted arms
here lately uh i don't okay people know
what that game is you know what's funny
like people will sit there and and they
will speak so highly of from soccer and
not even realize that they made that
game
like it's it's it's like it's a
turn-based game so from software has
made turn-based games
and what's funny is it was a launch
window for the 360. and i i don't think
people real like the 360 came out it
came out like three four months later
what enchanted arms yeah
yeah so i've been playing that because
i've been working on a video for uh the
youtube channel i've also been playing
dust falls yes
i love i love the footage i love the
decisions the the the beef back and
forth for those controversial choices
yeah and everything else i'm playing i'm
not allowed to talk about it oh
exclusive cool
iop that was a gaming exclusive
yes yes sir oh we got people joining
around we got everything shout out to
cedric h welcome back all that good
stuff so that's been pretty much it
yeah that's that's been pretty much all
i did watch that uh um oh lord of
the thor movie yesterday
yeah we can do a little improv after
everybody introduced things yeah yeah
i no doubt no doubt and of course coming
fresh off that two-week
pr vacation right a little pr yes sir
hello
okay the most technical gaming lord the
solo gamer list for a single player
selfish experience and also the
sastradamus the lord of clarity and lord
patron of the iron bank
my man lord sovereign how we doing sir
i'm doing fantastic sir i'm just
back and rested you know and she's nice
and she's good she's nice and the whole
almond
nice that nice and brown right
how's that
how's that
it was lovely i slept in damn there
every day your rest is a beautiful day
when you're watching yeah it's a
beautiful thing when you like you're
like i'm going to the beach at 3 p.m
like it's cool
it was just it was fun the last couple
days two were very like family oriented
because my parents arrived later later
on and uh with my sister and my niece
and my nephew um so it was cool because
they you know my dad again hasn't been
able to travel they were supposed to go
there for the holidays last year
yeah so you know he you know again his
you know physically he's not super
strong and he wanted to see the family
so we managed like on sunday we had like
a full on reunion so that was good
that was good so that was good i want to
give a shout out to everyone who uh who
super chatted to shame me for not being
here i appreciate your donation thank
you
it's well received thank you i love
y'all yes yes
and i'm back
i got a shout out out of order though
shout out to the homie heart geek shiny
two dollar super chat yeah
lords iop at full strength yeah it's
been a minute it's been a minute it's
back in a minute it's been a minute no
doubt any games on the way any any type
of chance to play
got that
i got the steam deck as so as did you
sir
um a lot of guys didn't got that yeah
they get right at the end of that that
whatever that that the beginning of that
third quarter so
yeah the new new miners over there so
thoroughly impressed for me like hey
i've realized something since i've moved
and the reality is that my time in front
of a television is going to be continue
to be super limited that's just what it
is right
so i'm like all right i'm missing out on
my my aaa gaming i'm missing out all of
it like i have my switch that's pretty
much it
and i'm like nah man like so
getting this i was like i'm hoping this
impresses me because i need to get my
aaa gaming on yes
and it
i got red dead in the palm of my hand oh
i got it i got witcher in the palm of my
hand i got cyberpunk in the palm of my
hand like
once
i'm fine like you know you're not
talking you got no you got to play
around to get see you know you know how
they say that 40s
no i mean that's what it is
[Music]
it's there no no no no no no you know
[ __ ] is extremely demanding
[Laughter]
this up pre-order no i didn't do that
and he's yelling he's yelling he's
yelling bang bang
i can't continue so so it's not for you
yes we know it's not for kangaroo but
it's not for me right now because like
you said you got to play around with it
oh but that i mean i think that's what
it is like it is a pc in your hand the
tinkering still goes down
anything that's steam deck verified
they're giving you sort of optimal
settings and it runs great and some of
those things will run in 60. um but you
know like something like that like a
little newer you're gonna have to mess
around with it um but like i said like i
got those games in the palm of my hand
and i haven't been able to play those
games in forever because i just don't
sit in front of a tv
and so i'm gonna tell you right now like
it did this paradigm shifting for me oh
oh oh
it's just what happened
the thing is
ain't no like again trash
what was this
the switch is a first-party console now
the playstation has always been the
first party concept
and even xbox you might not even xbox
right now because again i don't have yes
i don't have the time to sit in front of
the console
[Music]
cloud stream
this is you but you know my x-cloud
situation where i work i'm always in
some dungeon or a basement like x-cloud
ain't working
so it is one of those things that
hopefully they you know xbox and valve
start you know playing nice and we
figure out some native way to get you
know game pass pc on there but let me
ask you this though because you were the
connection i am so being that well not
exactly i'll have internet access when
i'm traveling a lot
but my question is you so you you're
saying is you need the native experience
to incorporate xbox in your thing right
but i would
prefer it so so my question is being
that you predominantly portable game now
you're remote a lot you're working a lot
would you consider buying the steam
versions of xbox games and playstation
games
as opposed to streaming at least in
xbox's case x cloud in xbox's case
depending on the game yeah for sure like
if it's something i really can't i don't
want to miss out like the big triple a
let's say yes you know yeah
i may end up copping that's why i'm
hoping they start you know playing nice
together when it comes to the
playstation stuff
it also it depends because with
playstation stuff i'm still not
confident that they're they're going to
go less than six months right
the cadence so if the cadence is short
yeah i may be tempted to wait if it's a
longer cadence i'll get it on
playstation whatever say let's say
random rock is like a six month is that
doable or you need to be part of the
zeitgeist playstation that's too long
yeah six months two years too long okay
i need to play ragnarok
but you know i could wait for strain
yeah what's that no you can do i mean
being there this is the pc situation you
know just boot like that's
what you're talking about
your throat your throat
[Laughter]
time so yeah that's pretty much it just
being kind of wild by that and just you
know you know when you get a new piece
of hardware you're like let me throw
this on there see like when you get a
new pc you're like let me see how the
old stuff runs right through that
one i haven't
yeah i got stuff to talk about too yeah
yeah so that's pretty much it um but i'm
excited for it and
every like the community around us crazy
like there's a lot i i cannot confirm or
deny that you know some playstation 3
gaming is going down yeah
a lot of configurability and options
i won't mention their name they're like
well i was like why don't i kind of like
the the nintendo games
and they're like well why don't you just
download the emulator and i'm like
because i play those nintendo games
online and you can't do that on me yeah
oh yeah you are live
let me get these super gentlemen
[Laughter]
let me get this super test real quick we
got cedric h member for 25 months shout
out to you sir thank you sir and of
course heart channing
yeah the one that you read shout out to
you sir hard to find remember for 15
months had to show love to the full crew
welcome the hashtag the deck boys solve
and push it and push and see put the
card
is for another 13 months my guys salaam
thank you sir
and what else we got we got lord of
roughness
super chat shout out to all four
horsemen back in the round thank you sir
while back was a
real quick um let me get a couple of
merches that i missed right there come
on where are we going someone got the um
iop in blue i believe little t classic t
leave a comment y'all leave a comment
somebody got that 20 ounce lords of
gaming.net
tumblr
salute you know what i'm saying there's
somebody else got the all the red iop
joy the red crispy red you know what i'm
saying you see the king rocking that
y'all yeah
i got the red
and the somebody cop the all-natty in
white you know what i'm saying so slow
put yeah they all that had the all-natty
and the white no doubt put that up make
sure y'all leave a comment on the
checkout um links in the top description
for the merge ilp log net just make sure
y'all leave it out so we can shout y'all
out we can actually get your balls off
when you copy the merch but that's all
yeah let me see uh what else okay real
quick i'll get these afterwards real
quick well i wanted to say it i almost
forgot
shout out to fedex for being the damn
worst oh they're the worst again
yeah they almost got me again
um
you you guys know that it's the same
dude it's the same dude it's the same
exact dude
if y'all remember if y'all remember i
had a yeah the phone where i was like
wow this google pixel 6 pro is really
light
because there was nothing in the box
yeah that's cool
so this time real quick story i had it
shipped to kai's house because i i
didn't know i was going to be back in
time
had to ship to his apartment it gets to
him i was back i was actually home i was
building some bathroom furniture and and
i had to go to work in the afternoon but
he was like i was waiting on his cold or
i could go pick it up so he gets the
notification that it's arrived but he's
like nobody knocked on my door open my
door nobody's nothing's dead so
immediately he runs downstairs he does
the right thing runs downstairs ask
security guard hey where's fedex he's
like oh they left the building or
whatever
and he was okay he calls fedex and lets
them know listen they said they
delivered this
and it's not here so he immediately
calls me right my reaction is they got
me
man on the steam
so i'm like i take a few moments to be
pissed off and then i call them back i'm
like yo no no it's like if you can get
away from your computer do me a favor go
back downstairs go to the two buildings
on your side of the of the complex
search and sweeps
the one before they're supposed to come
to you and they'll just deliver both of
them to that one that's so good yeah and
especially like the country but like
what's up with signature delivery y'all
especially with that bro because i had
it on bitty story i'll let you finish
what's happening and what's going on
he's in the bronx oh yeah i think it's a
hug
i ain't giving him that excuse because
they do that [ __ ] here
yeah well language stuff but
over there where
so you know they do come with body armor
and stuff like that
it's a fearful situation just get it
drop it off and then get out that's what
you're saying they on higher alerts
you should be on high alert from them
like that
yo king like you're we're not you you're
not stopping this this
this fedex bag in the future
yo
so we go he runs down as he's doing that
i'll be i said i'll be there in a minute
now
there's a parking lot in the middle of
our complex which is being renovated so
i can't go through i can't cut through
to his side i have to walk around
where your joint is you got to go up
jogging i'm like oh no
parkour he hopped over
the disaster
you know you got the quest marker they
got a question
you try
there's no truck to be seen there was no
truck on my side i was like god
and then so at that point like kai kai
after he did what he had to do but he
was sort of reserved to wait on customer
service to call him back i was like hell
no i'm not doing it yeah no no
i get over there we talked to security
guards and the other buildings that gone
right so i'm like all right damn what
are we gonna do now so i go back up to
the kai's apartment deluxe edition
edition i know where this is coming from
okay continue so we like
we're gonna go upstairs we're gonna call
them again we're like i don't like this
we call you when we find something out
no you're gonna call the driver the
driver should respond immediately yeah
this is not something that should take
time so we're gonna go upstairs and call
again as we're in the elevator
i'm like you know what
i'm gonna search every damn floor in
this building
to see
if they just dropped it over there this
is the best it turned into a game of
elevator action yeah that was elevated
action
yo that's exactly what it was so i'm
like yo i need these guys in an elevator
with dollies and like moving trucks i
guess they were either moving from an
apartment or something like that so i
forgot to hit the top floor because i
would go top floor all the way down you
got to hit the top floor they hit 15.
i'm like all right i'm gonna get off on
15 then they're gonna walk because they
otherwise it would have just taken me
down
get off on 15 i look over it because my
brother lifts the f line so i'm like i'm
looking towards the f line
see a box 15 f
walk over i'm like nah i can't be it's a
long box too it's just long yeah yeah
yeah yeah i'm like it can't be it can't
be i go over your name on it his name on
it because they had it oh cause you put
it initially on his name his address one
boy got he just dropped it off on the
wrong floor straight wow
that was god that took you to 15. it was
it was it
was like
oh
i was like i can't believe i was because
a lot of times you know this goes left
it just never goes
yeah this this is always a bad so so the
lesson learned when if that happens to
you
do not give up don't do do the customer
service inform them
but do your leg work and run people back
down
ladies and gentlemen run down on fedex
yeah
by all means necessary sir and of course
we have the incredible hulk of this aka
the access gamer who the prophet of xbox
swami king of the statues who demands
nothing less than that premium
experience it is the leader of the fraud
alert movement
beloved lord kig how are we doing sir
i'm doing fantastic so uh
throw a loving thunder um i couldn't
make it to the collector's um annual
cookout yesterday you know i had oh yeah
shout out to stuff going on shout out to
shout out to pcx and the whole family
and the tim
uh for putting on a hell of a cookout
todd for showing up and my boy christian
and everybody that was out there
um i'm pretty sure they had a good time
showing me thor cooking on the grill i
don't eat beef paws but uh he was out
there doing this thing cheffing it up
so so uh throw a love and thunder
yesterday
and um sir
taikawati
is a certified comedic genius like
uh i i think
he takes the light-heartedness of the
80s he's so steeped in the 80s you could
tell oh yeah his 80s 90s bag is
incredible the music from the music
to the gene claude van damme uh uh shout
out um
with some scenes oh yeah
i almost peed on myself when he was
looking at the bird creatures
absolutely bonkers but from from all
right so
from a historical comic book standpoint
right
it was probably
the most
heavy-handed
uh
call outs to books that i've ever seen
in in in in the marvel in any marvel
movie mm-hmm oh that's why it was so mid
then yeah you see it yeah yeah yeah
you know the kick rule okay all right
no spoilers please
a lot of times you know the layman dude
is the layman why you got to shame
somebody if they don't know every aspect
of this one i'm just saying you don't
see me going see go see 50 series of
gray and i'm not uh
if i'm not into bondage i think 50
shades of gray is going to go over my
head
you know
possibly be that the movie wasn't good
but if they didn't read
the wildest thing is hey guys be careful
of spoilers yeah i'm not saying we're
not spoiling that we're not spoiling
that i'm just not even talking about it
actually i'm saying i'm saying we're
arguing with king's logic
that's what we argue with i agree i'm
saying good on you i don't care it was
my it was
my this was my six it was my 67 sir not
yours i feel it all right so i went to
go see it in the hot maybe your movie
theater the screen was too small or
something going on hold on now we
shaving people
i like thor so anyway
i feel that
all the stuff that was there
i can tell
whoever sat there with him
knew
all the books and all the story lines
from christian bale being gog the god
the god butcher
and them not going full
alien with his look
and and staying humanoid
i thought that was a fantastic choice
yeah i like that character yeah you
didn't have to worry about a cgi ninety
percent of the time on the character
right right right
or all prosthetics and all this other
stuff because his face was able to come
through and show his emotion
that's the reason that like when you
look at like stranger things when they
did vega they're like that's not cgi
like that dude is literally cropped up
like
they he spent seven hours in a chair to
make that look like yeah
they nervously
i'm not saying anything about spoilers
i'm telling you if you read thought of
god butcher uh uh that book or you read
uh thunderstrike or you or you've read
uh uh attack on olympus
oh you read the mighty thor books then
there's no spoilers right if you if you
haven't whatever the hell i'm saying
right now is really actually gonna
deadpan in your ear but
for for
me from a visual standpoint i thought
the movie stood head and shoulders above
a lot of films because they didn't say
we're going to mcu it
let's go
like they're really stressed out
we're going to really stay very close to
the books as far as aesthetics goes
costumes go this is it was classic
costumes that you saw from you know
stuff so i mean if y'all saw any
trailers if you didn't see any trailer
i'm really not going into anything me
and addict is going to probably oh well
i guess all about it
yeah a round table review on it and
we'll do that this week or whatever yeah
and that'll get out there and y'all can
check that out but um for me yes yes it
was a nine i know for life it was a 10
when thor closed came off oh
shaq
yeah yeah her and like all the other
women inside the movie theater
what was funny is that i just looked
over like okay
face
what's funny is like my girl didn't like
i don't i could tell she didn't watch
too many of the uh the trailers so so i
knew that was coming like when you see
the actual
environment that was in the trailer yes
and then and then you heard it like oh
oh
you got to get that stern look
yeah no no you don't say nothing because
you know you don't want to come off as a
jealous
you just sit there and like word that's
wild
that's wild that's wow anyway
dope film
outriders oh
my god
oh first of all i want to shout out
ashton luca everybody sending well
wishes to ash and luca um
yeah it's it's it's a lot of things
going on and she has surgery oh oh
and i only saw it through the timeline
because um
you know um i think it was mav to put it
up and then i think fonz
did something else check it out
yeah i was just also one one other check
we got to check in on will me hood with
me uh someone came across my line and um
he was going through he's on a recovery
road right now but i know i didn't know
that yeah
they would have put the specific
business out but um he yeah he he was
going through it and he's on the
recovery right now trying to get his
strength back please reach out to
wilmington yeah
and also
yeah
louise assassinated
me i'm just you know
people
all right so thank god
well anyway
i'm playing outriders yes yes
and
all right so if your outright is dude
this game um if you like the formula
from before yeah you know minus all you
know the bs that came with it early but
if you stuck around with the game you
you understood that there was a lot of
minutiae and you can build your
character in certain ways and it was
building was all about damage and output
and stuff and you was doing runs and
expeditions trying to see the maximum
damage that you can do with overheat or
whatever
you you took
they doubled down
yeah
so hard on these builds
that i'm actually out there going to get
loot that i had already because now they
have a third tier on the gold loop
they made the gold loot more
inviting more exotic
if if if that was possible and then they
allow you to spec out your character
that only you gonna do this because
something that you're gonna find in
eighteen whatever you like you're gonna
build all your points towards what they
give you the freedom to do that's where
they got over the destiny i always care
about the builds the customization
beautiful i heard the end game i heard
the mod system the the new stuff i
remember really good things shout out to
chad guy drivers he's got a review up on
uh jen i've heard a lot of i got to get
to it yeah yeah yeah so we gotta get
that on lord to gaming.net oh yeah
anyway um
we got a steel tie yeah yeah yeah oh
yeah
shout out to that
um
i thought i thought
that they the way they did it now oh so
so when you're doing end game boss stuff
yeah
you know how in destiny you fight the
boss then you got to go through it
unless somebody saves the checkpoint
yeah they don't save the checkpoint you
can't come right back in you got started
whatever
they got to drink now
just like destiny but you don't have to
save the checkpoint everybody can go
back to lobby and then go right back to
the boss
and if they tell you you got four more
shots to get the loot that you want oh
that's what's up oh yeah and i heard
they took the timer out of the
expedition yes they did a lot of good
stuff
great stuff so you're no longer you
racing against the time for your loot
stuff it's really good
destiny i've been playing um
i i played four guys
shout out to dj orals in the chat that's
his game he loved him
cursed attic out what happened because
attic then put me on to another
diction
i've been i've been preaching for guys
he's been preaching for a long time yeah
yes would you know how to give an attic
you know how kick is if it ain't on xbox
yeah act
i don't care didn't show up but then it
showed up just came out i had no excuse
because you know game just dropped it
was looking really dope it was a brand
new game called the fall guys guys
check it out yeah actually it was it was
debuted by lord jean or or i went to
gaming. way before that when it was all
played
okay so when it just came out right now
released inside game pass
gene was in the future he you know he
has a right
yes but him and attic they they go the
future sometimes but this game
i'm with attic on this one
guys we got to sit together yeah let's
go let's go pick a saturday let's do it
how this is the better you'll be the
best
yeah that's that's what i'm doing i got
a couple of more games oh oh forza
i was in some forza bag
day before yesterday okay
i played fours of five fours or six and
fours of seven
just to find out the minutia that was
different in each game like the
motorsports and walked away
from all three of them saying
they always great in their own oh yeah
come on come on turn 10 that's what i
was like come on man like it's certainly
something
that's why i don't i don't
get caught up with all of this
management talk because there's certain
studios that's doing their thing and
have been doing their thing
studio
when you have
30 plus studios some of them are glass
it's just what it is i'll get to it but
miss management it's what half of them
ain't doing what they're supposed to
like yeah i feel that so anyway that's
about it sir
of course we have the gaming ninja
himself the [ __ ] no be low incognito
spread that real estate around the iop
i'll tell you what you want to hear what
you need to hear shout out to defining
duke shout out to my man mr maddie plays
we came back did a nice nice good one we
talked about our game pass where that
exists and some funny past criminal
activity
about mobile gaming it was kind of funny
they got me on blast they got statues of
limitations so i get i was able to talk
about it absolutely hilarious stuff and
why i don't do mobile gaming anymore oh
go check that out and then we i think he
got it to find new cop ultimate up on
our game collecting it's real cool as
far as the last word shout out to tyga
travis shout out to both this yo we had
an amazing building addict maze came
through
see all that a lot of us do tremendous
energy you see them doing big things he
got the budget commercial with destiny 2
the boy gave us a freestyle off top or
last word right as we started and put us
all in it was crazy but he's just he's
something else he's like i don't know
okay like one of them
what's what's this
what we said like the king of the
freestyle off top
from our cannabis
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah never make an album but the
freestyle yeah
yo stop putting my business
you wasn't supposed to say that that's
what episode yeah yeah
i see you yo yo
anyway
but that was one of the story so we got
that and um
obviously came back from vacay
and i'm saying shout out to everybody
shout out to rand outdoor pulled up when
i was in the show you know saying it has
a shout out to about i was using a very
dangerous situation well the last day
yeah the last day she was in florida
yeah and i'm looking at my timeline i'm
like what they talking about here okay
yeah i'm like this news in chicago yeah
should i be a spot you know i'm saying
shout out to my man lord suave
you know what i'm saying so you're doing
it big for the birthday happy birthday
happy birthday to you yeah happy
birthday
it was nuts it was nuts yeah i see you
so i'm out there
yeah i wasn't sure if it was a pantsuit
or a rope i think it's not a roadblock
that's something way outside but yeah
it was a role i'm out of control i'm
really out of control i was really
looking like rick ross that day
absolutely nuts um shout out to uh to uh
tom
oh
are we doing this yo shout out to tom
henderson we talk about god we talk
about god we talking about these yo yo
tom yeah and i'm calling you save you
save y'all listen loki shut up
see
i know why you didn't like thor loving
thunder because you wasn't in it loki
he got a
they had three pinocchio
with you in it yeah yeah loki
i don't got to be loki to take the knees
can you do your pre-order right now
there's a reason why
uh-huh
when when the company gets
uh unsolicited email pics of certain
persuasions
they have to stop this
so
god wore my slip
uh their fan base started sending
unsolicited pics
are you implied
mr corey balog was like excuse me
um
yeah
so so are you implying that because of
the pressure of a certain fan base by
doing very inappropriate things that
they were forced to to give a release
date that you don't believe
bruh when when when you wake up for 40
different unsolicited situations you're
like come on man
come on man how does that
[Laughter]
all right so they gave you a date right
do me a favor right now and go pre-order
it
oh my god wait wait wait a second wait
wait for it
listen i'll i'll wait
right with you mm-hmm
you you can do that can you do that so
what what happens when next week we
could pre-order what's that what's the
experience it didn't happen this week so
for right now until i see you next week
oh so because you can't pre-order you
know
this time machine his time machine is
wild crazy
the chat said you dammit king is dancing
yeah yeah yeah i'm dancing in the same
way i i'm dancing a lot of your games
dance into next year
we're full smoking oh
let's let's not because they had a date
too oh that's true that is
[Music]
god of war wasn't a topic you know who's
done they done uh sob because
i saw i saw cheetos bags
i saw taco bell ads
i saw
uh uh what was that um what was in the
supermarket uh pop-tarts a halo infinite
and then i saw it move
[Laughter]
i saw it and it was it was on the back
it was on the back of the box
i saw it on the back of the
he's like you got this this is coming
for you okay there's something happening
i i will give you that the halo infinite
thing was mad suspect but i do feel like
that was the exception not the rules
defense every other
playstation exclusive was delayed but
they've already delayed god award
yeah they did but you know what's the
best part about this one
this is the biggest game they got mm-hmm
where was the state of play
this was a strong arm from officers
it's coming a full on wake up in the
morning i got 3 000 unsolicited
situations in my dms and what is going
on and they said if you do not
why you gotta leave those victims or the
reason this happens
hey they there's a reason why they fan
base is like this because
if y'all know the history of the
playstation brand
it's tied to a certain hub
okay
here we go here we go statistics is that
demographic does that viewing a lot
so what they felt was it was okay to
solicit this information to the
developers y'all strong armor date is
not gonna stick they just quieted you
down right now uh-huh that's kind of
crazy if he's right about that it would
be great
strong on their way into a date
oh my no
let this let this game let this game get
delayed it'll be the day that i've been
i go
this will be one of the
the greatest escapes
this will be a real dd level d escape
this is this man and i just got to say
this to tom yes scared money don't make
no money
all right you're defending me yeah
you're right you where you two frey i
said your eyebrows he said oh hell
it would have been fun king puts it on
the line i can't even put all of it
because people were coming at me in the
town i had to restate what the bender
need was and i'm just like remember it
was because king i mean king initially
said yo i bet i mean tom was the one
that initiated right yeah he got it
was like yo i'll give a unsolicited
said no i don't want your money i want
your eyebrows so it was eyebrows
so they were about to come on screen
that's time on camera
shut up i feel that i feel that anyway
other other than that yeah man got my
steam deck been rocking and rolling um i
forgot to shout out my man midway
monster that pulled up and shot real one
here a real one
you should add on them
no god
shout out to nobody in the shower
weirdos shout out to everybody with good
fashion sense
shout out to all the people that had you
know they were really jealous they keep
making crocs for a reason because people
are buying no people i go for a kick do
i go for i had to get it i don't even
know yeah they're for children
i'm with p they were telling me because
we're doing a food tour so they tell me
you got to do super dog as far as the
hot dog getting there's like portillo's
super you guys kind of go to super dog
what else we thought was something i
ain't going for
pizza yeah no better hot dogs
hot yo they got us they've
nathan's is official but see where they
take it to the next chicago dogs take it
to the next level is the things they got
on it ain't pickles in the reality you
know but i think she you know what it's
good before you said a good quarter
yeah yeah like why why you got lasagna
on top of right now hold on let me shout
out red let me shout out random he gave
me some games give me chicago game now
deep dash look y'all it's decent it's in
the bushes it's not messing with new
york piece i'm sorry i you can feel how
you reveal you cancel your subscription
i don't care
it's not rocking with new york pizza
deep dish is not a go it's decent for
what it is
but oh no no no here we go now here we
go
oh mom we gonna get to that chat in a
minute but
now rand put me on the palmeros palermos
and that's chicago tavern style
tavern style pizza is like new york pete
tavis style that's the pizza y'all
should get
chicago tavern style is official that
tastes delicious because you know how we
like the tomato sauce the tomatoes you
know that the real goomba but feel you
know what i'm saying that official
that's the real joint table style salute
y'all
[Music]
hooked me up i was like bro this is what
i'm talking yeah he's like he's like yo
i'm just gonna i don't even like deep
dish i respect you that that was real
talk from the chicago inn but anyway so
that was that but um the hot dog though
all right so we did we did super duper
because i heard that oh yes sir
it was a family next to me so paul said
yo don't look you're gonna be bad i was
like what's up look they all eating this
super dog they all had crocs on
i was like i them tell king this this is
christ so anyway that was official hey
shout out to portillo's um dog is cool
but they got one of the best italian on
beef sandwiches i've ever had sausage
and peppers almost like that mulberry
street what's that joy song we used to
go to mulberry street the italian goomba
with the mobs yeah yeah yeah
it's little italy italy yeah go to the
whatchamacallit the festival the feast
of sanchez yeah it's like freezing
style with the it's official and they
got this thing called a chocolate cake
shake oh man i'm about to run like two
oh yeah they blend up the chocolate cake
bro it's like they're putting cake in
there man they come in for the tie the
only one i would say so okay from what i
hear from what you said for what i've
seen that town is full of diabetes
it grows it can get dangerous for your
weight it could get dangerous
what i hear is you got a pizza with
everything what is not a pizza with
nothing the pizza with everything a hot
dog with everything like they they are
the day of the town for the excess yeah
yeah everything is yeah they do it they
do it
yeah absolutely absolutely so that
that's pretty much it as far as b just
game wise um i'm gonna be the
showstopper rocking that finish that's
the story mode got my steam deck you
know what i'm saying rocking that loving
that what was your first game that you
played um actually though
damian was fired on steve dick i was
like oh my god dude kai showed me how to
do the configuration joint i threw on
for attic or like x x-com chimera squad
why is there no console port what's
going on x-com chimera squad we have
mark norton on developer for the game
y'all got to get that together you know
what i'm saying so we do that shout out
to dj orals hashtag sketchy
we coming for kaiba to your brother your
brother what happened brother with the
best thing we had was being here began
before taking the chat and your bad talk
about getting us locked up for trying to
play destiny a certain way but he did
say
he do what it do geforce now or
streaming because we like yeah we
talking about that last night yeah cause
he we cuz he so i'm teasing for a time
let's risk it all let's read let's have
bungie ban our accounts and child and
all this what
[Music]
wait wait wait oh yeah you can't get me
oh it's a wrap
your account is mine do not launch it
there's an an issue with the um the
protection yes
same i think for it no it's not does
fortnite not work for guys none of the
epic game joints
does fortnite work i don't know we have
to defer to the the future i don't
remember it we will talk too soon yeah
we'll talk about it
um yeah like so basically just don't do
it and it was a fun discussion because
you know you know your brother
yeah your brother's funny your brother
got his methods so yeah he knows this
yeah that's a new piece of hardware so
he's sitting there trying to decipher
the letter of the lord of forte and dj
orals and they like die we are
to hear like the reasoning if he got
banned for it too
you know how kaibatsu get when he feel
he knows something you wrong and then
they like know we until you tell us that
they knock over ben is we not doing it
yeah
though yeah i would say i wouldn't
because if he brought y'all in and y'all
and you guys believe him and you all get
banned
i'm like yo let's just go rob this bank
together let's just risk it all
[Music]
let's go see what happened he didn't end
well
i was doing my heat my little pacino you
know what i'm saying but yeah it was
funny that was a fun discussion so i was
doing that and then um yeah other than
that on the rocker blade point and then
um as far as how are you liking it i
like it i like it's a different we got i
love being you to check because it to me
is channel five battle royale with the
essence of of a lot of kung fu stuff we
like and i think you're going like i
think i'm gonna try
to
so i played it on a pc before
so
i'm going to give it a chance on the
xbox because i want to know the controls
let's squat a million squats battle
royal and this like might be a joint for
us it's very different but the parkour
the roof joint and then they got the
everybody got their guard or their
little special power yeah i kind of like
it but anyway so look enough of that we
have gone on long enough without the
floor
jeans background you have a very good
real quick i don't know my name for jean
is the magic man yeah the magic man
let me just let me just uh skip protocol
for a second and read these two super
chats because shout out to heart gate to
me hooking up the community first off
congratulations whoever got this first
code forza horizon 5 premium there's a
code in there have you got it shout out
uh hargie cheney thank you my brother in
the chat um and then additionally to
that he put forza horizon 5 premium
add-ons bundle the global code is also
in there so somebody else could have
gotten that thank you so shout out to
whoever got that in the chat and shout
out to you heart key to me always
wrapping all the way make sure yo can i
ask y'all to sub today yes i know we
asked for the light it'd be a lot but
y'all got to start subbing to the chat a
lot of y'all in here that's not
something we provide
entertainment right now i'm gonna tell
you this movie reviews
get another console but y'all just don't
want that
i don't want another console so y'all
need to watch that playstation five i'm
not like you i will get you a
playstation 5. i'm not going to sit
there and wait for the black friday
discount people
subscribe and then we can go and you
know we'll pay the extra so you can get
it exactly so all right cool cool so
we're going to caught up with the other
protocol drums yeah that's it i read the
i read the
i know what it is we don't want to put
knees up i don't know why these came up
but that's all right
anyway so look it's that time when i'm
off y'all again
lords of gaming.net
tremendous team
tremendous talent great scribes gotta
shout out everybody doing their thing we
have some of the best up and coming
journalists in the realm competition
every month for this award is extremely
fierce but um we're blessed man we got
some quality reviews opinion pieces tech
breakdowns lord's minutes but of course
there is one scribe who went above and
beyond in the month of june he truly had
an exceptional month when it comes to
that lords of gaming.net war room y'all
when it comes to that war room when it
comes to these big events whether it be
the pax's in this case the summer game
fest the sony state of play the xbox but
that's the game showcase he's in there
he's pumping the articles he's doing
that not only did he did that he had one
of the hottest tmnt
shadow shredders revenge reviews up
ordnance shout out to him on that one
and on on top of that you know say his
if you haven't checked out yo check out
his steam deck hardware review nice
little size comparisons all the devices
he's been a vet in the game one of our
ogs and we proudly present last the
latest winner of the lord that lord
dizzy scribe of the month of june
gene
shaft chaff my i got it right hopefully
i always put you this man last night you
got it chef maya aka lord 37 gene 37 my
man welcome and congratulations for a
tremendous mom
thanks guys king you're you're going to
love this story this is going to really
help you out you're going to fuel your
your steam deck hatred
i put a i put about 30 hours into the
steam deck uh for the review that week
and uh saturday morning i woke up to
start writing so i i got the it was
delivered on a saturday so saturday
through saturday but about 30 hours i
wake up saturday morning start writing
and there's a tennis ball sized lump on
my elbow from playing the steam deck for
30 hours non-stop
whoa wow
yeah it's it's heavy it's big it's a lot
bigger than the switch um
i just don't recommend it elbow
wow
it's a heavy device it is a heavy device
y'all there's no doubt about it it is
that is an adult situation well what i
would tell you uh gene is uh maybe if
you remove the sound and lower the
resolution to get light down
it's ridiculous
though
now brother you've been killing it
that's my favorite speech give me
something um you know i love working
with you guys all the team we have we've
got a really great team it was a a
fantastic fake e3 this year
uh next year i can't wait to see you
guys in person it sounds like it sounds
like you know based on who's running the
show it sounds like we will be there uh
yeah and and uh
running the show again and then just
11 months now it's a countdown
so we're all hanging out again yeah but
we got we got packs first
good that's a good point that's a good
point yeah we got packs yo gene we
always hang out so we got packs first
yeah i wonder what they're gonna do pax
if um read pop is running packs in
june i'm sorry uh e3 in june are they
gonna do packs in late april maybe they
move that up a few months hopefully so
hopefully we're hanging out sooner we'll
see what they do yeah no doubt man it
will be great to see you up in the flesh
doing what we're doing i'm going to
choose his magic powers again
the
the suit jacket on the interviews you
know i'm saying it again we need that
but uh keep doing your thing brother
you've been absolutely killing it love
what you bring to the team and the
professionalism is off to charleston one
of the very best lord gene
chef
on twitter 37 gene 37 follow me there's
a more switch more uh steam deck content
coming out this week okay now that i
have two functioning arms
get you the arthritis and tennis elbow
make sure you hit solve up get whatever
you need and uh sir we see you back up
in here man it's been every a couple of
months just but he always find his way
back
all right see you guys all right brother
have a good way enjoy your sunday man
yes sir is that top of the month once
again to say thank you to our patrons
thank you so much for your support we
truly appreciate you so let's get these
giveaways underway
right so our ten dollar gift card
giveaway goes to
[Music]
joe bell joe bell nobel that's a new
name that's a new name
all right we're not rigging official
records shut up
the bag was dropped off
thank you joe i appreciate it
that we have
our 20 gift card giveaway and that goes
to
albino dread okay
you sir
i know dress silly albino dread
and of course we have our tea spraying
giveaway we'll get the trip
let's see who gets the trip let's go
and our teespring giveaway for the month
of july goes to
drop dead face man
[Music]
yes sir yes sir thank you very much for
the support we appreciate everything you
guys do to help us be who we are thank
you yeah thank you thank you so we're
gonna get into it finally into these uh
times of the show no uh poll last two
weeks or whatever it was so we get one
at the end of the show get back into
that case
how many how many unsolicited picks you
think
yo you you missed you you didn't really
let me play with my jewelry oh yes
you didn't read a certain super chat
but i didn't read i i was gonna say let
me read the super chats we have two now
right oh yeah
let me read all the super chat
and while he's getting that together we
have uh almost 500 people that's not
yeah
the chat could you please hit that like
subscribe
and share it out with a friend that
needs to laugh at this moment
so just so y'all know the last thing
that i have in case anything jumps in is
flames good afternoon my brother so
that's the last one salute to the flames
that's the last one that happens
all right so we have first we have
cedric h member for 25 months thank you
sir
then we got donald taku member for 14
months thank you my brother if you like
rpgs like divinity definitely play
solasta on game pass definitely not on
the same level as divinity but it's
still a great game so far did everybody
have a problem downloading it the first
thing because the first day i saw it pop
up i was trying to download it and i
kept getting uh error message but then i
was able to download it the second day
after okay okay
and we got hustle and motivation
remember for 18 months thank you brother
thank you brother hold me right thank
you exactly exactly
hello
exactly co-host of the attic show hello
all great to see the four horsemen of
gaming back at it yes it is good to be
back sir all four the full strength
and we got donald taco ten dollar super
chat everyone needs to ignore that god
of war ragnarok please hold the date
that they're now
it will release in 2023 because king
proclaim did hashtag 97 percent right
okay
why how why my knees getting chopped i
didn't say what did i say yeah he wasn't
here
throw me into the mix i i did say that i
think it's coming out this year but i've
been no knees
he don't trust somebody like that
yeah i don't know that's my association
then we got shroom kingdom two dollar
super chat glass off with the non-lethal
route yes yes there was no fedex driver
two killed so thank you
him and i are two different people
they got
let's get them likes up and keep pushing
that powder
oh yeah what we doing today we focusing
right now go to vsg.com you know what
i'm saying get that get that we all rock
we're focusing right now we got that uh
strawberry lemonade right there
strawberry
i heard you got a whole new flavor
getting ready dropped oh we got new
flavors going on yeah head on over there
advanced gg.com you know what i'm saying
put in cold iron check out get that 10
off on the discount you know what i'm
saying powder yeah i got that i got that
sour apple rocking right now
yes sir
and we got hollywood rules member for
six months thank you my brother lord
silva the fantastic four are back and
complete listening to iop while at work
saw thor yesterday and i think the
verdict will be split can't wait to hear
what you think oh we the fantastic four
i'm the human torch
[Music]
i i guess we're gender flopping the
invisible yeah we're clearly going to do
a swap
right back at you exactly continue yeah
we got it dragon heart yo me tv member
for 13 months thank you sir salute
thank you brother
we got fonzarelli gaming shout out to
you sir 14 months
it's really good to see you four back at
it you've been missed thank you my
brother no doubt absolutely phone's
around let's put the crest in the chat
for the newest member around brickhouse
[Applause]
and we got brett bingham 20 super chat
forza motorsport 4 was the best
motorsport game changed my mind it had
the best multiplayer with private
lobbies and the best lobby gameplay
options it's not backwards compatible
though yeah that's the sad thing about
those that even though those are first
party games they have licensing stuff
that kind of keeps them i think seven is
seven you can't purchase any money yeah
yeah yeah talk about licensing stuff
later yeah i got it yeah some of that
stuff you need those racing games you
need physical mm-hmm facts
we got shroom kingdom member for 19
months thank you sir
lil johnny about to get you guys
starfield's release date brb right oh my
god
oh yeah why why what do y'all think okay
let's see
the date let's say
why would they pick that instead of the
11.
um
supposedly it's a a day in um north
mythology it's supposed to be odin's day
or something yeah
yeah you're gonna come out on thor's day
too
the biggest thing i'm like i'm very
skeptical with is they're not having a
third one so this is supposed to
conclude like the north the north
mythology stuff
so i'm just like
what
how are they going to
finish
the
the uh what's your name uh story plot
fear
fetish thor and finish odin in one game
like any way they did in thor ragnarok i
mean loving thunder
gotta rush it
very fast
no but like yeah i mean this thing is
this if this is you're assuming this
game should be a longer game than what
you would expect from just the sequel if
you knew the third one was coming right
so oh
we'll see a huge dlc
wow here we go
then we got freddy fox five dollars
king has a point either they're gonna
move the date or god of war gonna be a
buggy mess how the game falls how is the
game four months away they're still
showing cg trailers
shout out to y'all he'd be sleep
slapping what's up back today
actually there's a regular super chat oh
you should be two dollars from chat
ragnarok is not going to be the d pick
game yeah
i don't think this i hope this game is
rated just like the other one is but i
don't think it's going to be you don't
think it's going to be as good as the
first one i mean no it's not going to be
at least i i don't think it's going to
rain as highly yeah added adequately
consistent with that yeah
and and his and his his his
reasonings why
very sound here we go
it's just i i just feel like they
switched up that formula once
you can't have that it's not gonna
and um he's in alignment with both of
you like he's just saying that like
there was the newness to the the god of
war formula when it changed dramatically
he's not saying it's not gonna be a good
game
he's just thinking that he thinks more
along the lines think like high 80s as
opposed to yeah
i don't know you do that new move and
then you know they say right you'll move
and then you try to do it again it's
just not as you know it just depends on
how the story is that the story is sound
they might be able to pull an id plus
yeah but if the story is crazy like if
they you know they murder cradles
straight up like or something like that
like she said kratos has a car now major
change i can't
[Music]
if it comes out this year what the
comparison between eldon ring and
golovkin
got some stiff competition yeah elderly
skull and bones man
no you did not no you moved
[Laughter]
real that video game awards is going to
be interesting this year like
i didn't do anything
i i could see god of war beating elder
ring for game of the year but they got
to bring it bring it back but do you
think god of war gonna beat skelembon
[Laughter]
gonna do anything yeah he's gonna vote
they both announced the release they
after god of war
and they dropped the trailer they was
like so what we heard
you triggered my trap card
i'm gonna tell you this
if god of war does move
we need more people imagine if your
score is higher on medicare don't even
do this i'm not even entertaining this
foolishness
rock the block like you can't pump over
here
the audacity
we're going to get a game pass
announcement in the next couple months
oh forgot to walk don't know
the only thing that's going to save the
scholar in the street
it's a name too it's not like they're
gay it's hilarious it sounds like
somebody that don't care tell them
i thought song was joking i had no idea
they had that
bro they have they have the tuesday
ragnarok is wednesday or something
you know what's the craziest thing what
i'm coming out the kitchen
why is he sitting there watching tv
i'm like what you're watching she said
just this new game this is the game you
look at that that game look crazy i'm
looking it's skull and bones just show
the black dude with the dress
i said what the hell
i guess it's gonna
put their flag down they were gonna see
what happens it's gonna be interesting
with skull and bones they're very
interesting what's scary about skull and
bones
i'm looking at i'm like okay where's the
third-person game like if you're gonna
lean into black flag
and there's no combat off the boat
it's supposed to be everybody really
they didn't seem too confident in
showing i like to think of this let's
move on from the skullenbones yeah
yeah i started it
i feel that you're like starting the
show
ah
let me play with your joystick
wow speaking of unsolicited picks
sob i'll give you permission to slide
into my dms at any time yo
wow
that's
ah
[Laughter]
thank you for your support
johnson remember for six months shout
out to
chicago
oh okay i always forget
oh [ __ ] remember that is because yeah i
got chad johnson yeah she checked i
always forget my apology what'd she say
what she said no she says she says
chicago hate will not be tolerated
listen most of us in shy natives eat
tavern style not deep dishes oh cool
that's but that's for
what i was trying to do
is i was trying to go to harrows but
then i was close to old block and we
said no so that was the last chicago
thing
i got i gotta we gotta have an
intervention at some time with cog
um because uh your man likes to go to
the most dangerous neighborhoods in the
world to go try the news uh food choices
is either gonna be a new show on iop
called dangerously searching for food
starting to sound like you know what
you're starting to sound like black
magic we gotta go we gotta go
he sent me to atlantic city he's
listening to that spot i said you were
fired
it's fire the block is a the to get
inside the joints it's fire because the
block is on but i have to get through
hellfire to get there but the food will
be fired why we driving right
right wifey rolled up the window
wow yo i'm dead serious and i'm looking
like what the hell happened to this
neighborhood and and then at the same
time [ __ ] text me did you get there
yeah
listen man i'll be outside i gotta go
for the fools to tell anybody move it
once again five dollar super chat
uh for those with game pass no here this
is the same way you said before this is
the thing you got lord metroid member
for 10 months i just checked the fall
guys store for the first time they're
selling a chapel in colorado outfit i
grew up watching the show in pr salute
at chapel in colorado a.k.a
yeah
these are these are shows honestly i
didn't grow up with this because i was
here and i didn't really watch uh
spanish language shows when i was
younger
um but my wife that she was all about
one of those spanish people she's
hanging out with the dogs and black
fix your people time time for you do you
but i learned after his wife was like oh
no no no you need to you can't let me
you got to fill this in he was eating a
lot of soul food
i think
then we got uh armando sanchez member
for five months
uh my first live episode in a while the
whole crew is here that's a lord's day
right there have a great show and you as
well man you as well
we got thx eleven thirty eight five
dollars
god award november ninth release is a
wednesday
what triple a game ever released
i feed it into the bs friday god award
i'm telling you it is the skullenbones
effect
who i will gun drop yeah exactly there
we go flame five dollars but good
afternoon my brothers i might be too far
gone in warframe but you can count on me
to make it to e3 next year first rounds
on your board let's let's go
down we drink the leblancs
we out there you know that now we got
gaming forte 10 super chat wait a minute
king before i do my celebratory message
why do i feel like i was on the deserted
island this entire year about a god
entire year about god of war being
delayed the 2023 i didn't see i didn't
see you when you back when backup was
needed so i guess he had the same the
same thinking i don't remember
i guess
i was on that island with you forte but
then when these dabs started coming out
saying stuff i jumped off yeah
[Laughter]
once again wow somehow pulling out a
forza motorsport 7
shout out to whoever got that in the in
the chat
um and then we have let me see i think i
got jumped real quick yeah we roll back
for a minute
super chat i'm sorry but mario plus
rabbit sparks of hope is bodying
ragnarok
they actually put effort into making the
game into a sequel and not a deal wow
[Music]
i mean that's that's a hill to die on
that's for sure
then we got brett bigger five dollars we
had skull and bones was originally
intended to be a black flag dlc but
became its own game that's what happens
when dlc takes time to mature
you know what's crazy
my camera says it's not on and zoom
no you guys it's on like hell no on mine
it's black oh really oh really now you
go but it still works somehow like i'm
going to know what you're drinking maybe
disconnect whatever but you're good
right now everything goes faster be
careful all caught up together your
joint is off whenever we got out butt
naked go to the bathroom yeah yeah yeah
do nothing out of pocket because we can
see it don't
[Laughter]
[Applause]
there should be there should be no skin
touching that expensive chair sir
yeah
that's a secret lamp like
himself
[Applause]
[Music]
have a great lord's day
he threw the ball
let's go all right are we good hold on a
second let me see let me roll back they
always get jumped in the blocks
we're good we're good we're good
it's really my fault because i miss you
i'll miss you too
you gotta take it i'm gonna leave and
come back this black screen is annoying
all right cool all right
let's go hurry up all right cool
i don't know
because he want to know what he can see
anyway
so uh get kicked this is your topic but
i'm gonna set it up for you man uh yeah
battlefield man battlefield's in the new
hail infinite in the news it looks like
it overtakes halo infinite in steam
shout out to our good friend tom
henderson who was one of the first to
put the report this morning eyebrows
eyebrow our guy you know says yeah
battlefield 2042 has managed to retain a
pretty decent player base this was july
5th since it launched and he said at
that time i think peak all online for
all time uh for 2042 is equal to 105 000
users in the hill infinite and again
this is on steam you know i'm saying 272
000 and that 24 hour period that i guess
tom reported it was about 6 000 about a
little above 6 000 um
of that on what you call it on
battlefield against the uh 5 000 for
halo infinite so that was kind of like
the first news type that we're going to
jump in but i did want to include also
your topic you don't have to talk about
this part but some other developments
that happened a couple days ago shout
out to windowscentral.com
um shout out to um yeah they put out
they talked about our former bungie
director from 343. joining 343 now to
work with halo infinite so what we need
to know that uh paul bertone has joined
343 industries to work on halo infinite
he signed on his technical design
director in his position he will help
bridge the gap between design and
programming and he originally worked on
bungie's five halo games before leaving
the studio in 2012 working with other
developers like undead labs before
returning to halo in 2022 and joseph
staton put out an announcement
announcing their signing so let's get
back one point with king's initial topic
battlefield surpassing hitting on steam
how do we feel kings which was
that's out of control yeah like because
the state that the game shipped in is
shipped in such a broken state
that you didn't think that it would be
able to recover because remember the
whole language around it was you should
have put it in game pass
and microsoft uh bet on halo
this is what's the thoughts you know
microsoft better on their own product
and then better on the outside product
with ea
and
um yeah did microsoft take the wrong bet
because uh
you know battlefield from what i heard
they dropped
14 to 17 different updates
uh recently stealth updates to said game
that helped balance to help uh graphics
that helped control
that fixed a lot of uh issues quietly
without making noise about it
and
they're consistent with their cadence in
that game and sticking by it and giving
to the the core fan base
and i don't think halo is doing that
i don't think halo is giving anything to
their fan base uh and this is just on
steam yeah oh it knows what the other
numbers look like well i got all the
numbers for you um
now the thing is you know man
no no i mean it surprisingly i mean in
steam this is definitely what you said
now on xbox per se the last time i
checked they were number they were just
within the top 20. so they were number
18 on games played right so they fell
out the top 10 barely in the top 20 but
they're number 18 as i checked them
yesterday let me check right now check
right now and then yeah um yesterday
also
battlefield is nowhere to be found on
xbox like i looked at top 50 battle
stills
so battlefield hasn't recovered on on
xbox or the console yet but on the pc
side in battlefield's defense to your
point like yeah like that you know
they've made improvements and it's
definitely higher engagement there
versus a fun to play game
and as far as the developer um that went
back to uh 343
uh
from um
from bungie yeah my question is did he
have to get back that million point five
that sony gave which is remember they
had to retain
they each person
[Music]
that billion dollars they had uh don't
leave me fee no no no he won that he won
that destiny when he left
he went over there like he he left
before he joined but when bungie was
about before the battle he left before
the bad guy yeah yeah he left the boy
i know he got that phone call he was
like yeah sony purchases
let's be real here if he was there
wouldn't that bad drop he wouldn't have
left yeah for sure he got that million
five yeah
let's talk about it your camera's back
well not cause i'll see it yet
go get me next all right get you there
all right so i'm hoping you make it yeah
um so
start with you man like what do you feel
about this news battlefield you know
overtaking halo infinite on steam and
then the recent addition to um the as
far as the director jordan 343 former
budget director
so the battlefield thing is super
surprising to me just because
it kind of feels like i remember you
guys remember a while back they were
like
there was a whole thing where i forgot
who it was that that maybe it was
shreyer or maybe it was great i think it
was grub it was grump
that said something that indicated to
that you know he he made it seem like
they had like a skeleton crew working on
it now like they were they had
essentially moved on right and that
everybody perceived it as you know they
moved on completely there's like 10
people working on the game or something
like that and that was an exaggeration
obviously he's like well there's still
hundreds of people working on the game
but
they if kind of the the core of that
team the bigger part of that team has
moved on to work on whatever the next
battlefield is going to be so what it
leads me to believe is that whatever the
core of this battlefield is it can only
be fixed so much
and it can only be addressed so much uh
without spending a ton of money to sort
of reboot it completely
um
so i you know to see that it's coming
back i mean i guess it's good for them
because you want to
at least take this this battlefield
which was disappointing from the onset
you want to at least take it to the best
possible place it can be so that leading
into your next battlefield people
that love that game will be a little
more trusting of you
so hey
to see that is coming back means that
there's work being put into fixing the
things that people had issues with right
um you know my impression is that the
next battlefield will have a story mode
proper and all this stuff and it'll be a
complete package
and to sort of offset any
sort of
bumps in the road you're gonna have with
multiplayer anyway right but when when
you your whole game is multiplayer if
you're not it's that's not a tight
experience out of the gate you're gonna
have problems doesn't matter who you are
right
and so to see this
to see that okay to see that battlefield
is has overtaken sort of halo infinite
and who else have they overtaken well it
was just that was the main comparison
infinite yeah so i mean it goes to show
that
and i said this from the beginning when
it comes to halo infinite i'm like the
multiplayer core of it right the people
that love halo are going to gravitate to
that
but the fact of the matter is that
they've turned it into something else
when you turn it into a service based
game you have to have you have to be
ready for content content content
content
and and and it's obvious that the halo
infinite team was not ready for the
cadence that they needed to keep up that
game and keep it in people's minds and
keep people playing it um obviously we
will talk about you know well
okay so we'll talk about was it paul
bertone coming over tony coming over
paul bertone coming over um obviously
he's been working on destiny he's been
working on it he didn't actually have
another stuff he didn't work on that but
he was on halo one through three two
three on reach and i believe odst right
and then after that he went where um
they is kind of like doing his thing
looks like um i'll get you the back
story
look like um the state of decay i know
he helped yeah
he worked at bungie from 2000 to 2012
because i think that's 2014. 14. so he
said help the developer launch
all five of the taylor games and he left
the company ahead of his transition from
halo ahead of
the transition to destiny and then in
years since he's worked with several
game studios over the years including
state of decay state of the gate 2 and
before returning into halo now in uh
2022. okay okay
so at the core of it if he doesn't if
the experiences he's had with uh with uh
like undead labs and whatnot weren't
necessarily online sort of
infrastructure
uh sort of related then at the core of
it then he's just a guy who knows halo
and knows what the fans want of halo
much like a joseph staton so to me
having again having these core halo guys
back to bring back that core experience
and make sure that you keep the halo
fans engaged with the hope of continuing
to bring in new people um i think it's
the right move i think anybody that that
that is part of core halo bringing it
back hey cause to me that's
that's where it lives like to me like i
said before i was like you when you turn
halo into something else
you ha it you have to be ready to rock
and if it's not then you're gonna
you're gonna double back and just focus
on what makes you good right focus on
what makes halo great and then little by
little continue to improve the back end
of what a service based game is right
and i have no doubt they're doing that
but at the end of the day
i'm gonna keep it a buck with y'all
let's go i thought i thought that the
campaign gameplay-wise was fantastic
in terms of the story in terms of
epicness and not so much
we need we need the halo story to be
epic again we need those sort of
water cooler moments again i didn't see
a lot of that in halo infinite's
campaign gameplay though fantastic um so
to me bringing these guys back is is
securing that or hopefully securing that
okay that's where i feel that's what i
found
what oh god sorry
i got the
most played up so double click my uh
picture
um
yeah so pretty much
it actually a little surprising um you
know obviously fortnight's number one no
one uh you know i'm watching this
trailer up here
i got to give my hats off to this
company it's just crazy the stuff they'd
be putting in this game
like when you think that they done they
come up with eight other ways to
to push their brand then you got war
zones fall guys is three on one
came out four guys and i mean they had a
big comeback they kind of quieted down
and this was
free to play cross play it just blew up
again
so then we got uh gta 5 which
is kind of crazy
apex legends
rainbow six siege
so more people are playing rainbow than
infinite yep uh we got more people
playing minecraft yes
there's more people playing far cry 5
than that than hey
crazy
[Music]
i will say it is i am intrigued that
what's uh
six twelve four okay
yeah it's about the same yeah i just
came out in game pass though and we have
four guys wait the [ __ ] is free to play
though
no i'm talking about um
oh fox right just came in game pack yes
yeah it seems like a lot of people
didn't play that game because they don't
know i didn't i weighed it yeah me too
thank you thank you
so much
but yeah so i mean
if you look at the these talks
hold on hustle and motivation halo's day
like i said the chat always here but
apology what is he talking about what's
this don't really owe you anything
why they don't want to fight
what happened the the the chat is a
giant beast you could try to get that i
don't think you're gonna get
it so you know you got if you look at
these top games though like what's crazy
is a lot of these
are free to play stuff and halo is free
to play too
so it should be higher on this dude like
dead but dead by daylight is it has more
people playing it than halo and i
thought it said bug snacks was beating
halo i was about to run out the room
roblox i thought it said snacks
it's
[Music]
they can't separate
[Laughter]
it's not good and that game is and let's
be honest the elephant in the room is
the game is free to play
sir king you was going to laugh and then
you were going to get his balls off
after you no no i'm just saying it just
seems like microsoft has purchased all
the bungie's old stuff
and got bungie back
without actually doing it they went and
individually plucked everybody
we like you
we like you
they got the whole core of bungie and
what does butch
you funny great
your thoughts on this whole thing man
uh hold up i'm trying to figure out why
my my cam's not working again i'll
remove the pen
get back but um
i sent you yeah it is what it is
like you know i am
sensitive
[Laughter]
i do feel like
halo could still bounce from this but
you know they they
the longer it takes for them to release
content the lower the ceiling that they
can hit ghosts yeah and i feel like it's
it's getting low man it's you know
they they had the potential to be as big
as fortnite in war zone in them now they
i don't think they ever have that
potential i think uh it's we we are
below that
and right now they could come out there
and be like a rainbow six siege or or
you know or a rocket league and if they
wait longer than that it's going to go
even lower so i said
when that co-op drop check the numbers
again
[Music]
people already be a lot of people
already beat the game man i don't think
co-op is going to just sure it will get
people in there to say oh you know i can
grapple hook when you're driving
yeah well i gotta be there boys
i i i don't i don't think you're gonna
see jurassic people stay in there like
people will jump in there just to test
around for a co-op experience
i think forge would be people would be
the uh yeah the ability to keep people
in the game i agree i don't think that
co-op doing much
when when people get a chance to fiddle
with it
i like it now
not fair i mean let's see i i'll get my
joints off um
i'm sorry
i don't know that i'll get my balls off
look
this is crazy like the battlefield thing
part is is a bit surprising because
solve you all remember with battle with
halo
infinite multiplayer stealth dropped
battlefield was like yo wait what's
what's going on yeah what's going on
what's happening then they had they had
but they had the stakeholders meeting or
something and it was kind of like they
blamed
partly blame they they won't i remember
that they want to fix it with that but
they partly blamed halo infinite for
battlefield uh uh initial poor reception
and
one of the factors that it was not
received yeah wow have times have
changed change and um look it's just not
good you know i mean the engagement
number is over there but i want to give
battlefield they flowers in a sense that
look they got my man over there they got
fans
one thing see this is what ea did he say
oh we our big friend is not doing what
he's supposed to do
get vince on the phone he's becoming the
fixer i'm calling victor not a fixer you
know i'm saying get the fixer on the
phone let's get him over there and this
is a short i don't even know they made
changes all this fast and they trying to
get their core game play and now they're
in there doing what they got to do now
for the xbox portion of the i need to
get that game pass back stop playing i
should have did that from the beginning
man king always said battlefield should
have did that but you know they were
feeling himself or whatever but he's
feeling that
yeah he's feeling himself but um look as
far as um you know the three four three
thing i like this higher i think this
high is a fantastic high i'm with king
you got to get back to the core essence
of what made you great you know joseph
stayton a tremendous thing for him to he
was you could tell he's very proud he
put the tweet out this is my guy he was
there from halo one to three and to me
to me the key sentence he said he said
um
he said but tony they helped to bridge
their eye the gap between the studio
design and on programming teams assuring
that developers are able to create
content with their tools smoothly and
without hindrances and to me that's the
most frustrating part of halo infinite
they are not able to get content out in
a timely fashion for a live service game
right so if he can assist in this
process then this is a great hire and
i've said it look i'm tired of beating
up on d3 i said it a zillion times the
game should be delayed i'm gonna die on
that so i don't care what y'all say
these numbers is not a good look they're
just not yeah you know for a this is a
core
pillar
franchise you cannot say
nintendo's treating mario zelda like
this you can't say sony is treating last
of us or spider-man or whatever like
this there's certain franchises that
that's that's brand association and for
this to be in this state it's just they
got to do what they got to do i like
these steps you know i like and i say
again
i like
what staten is doing i feel you should
empower him because the fact that this
man got up off his couch
no one asked him no one called joseph
state where halo infinite was doing bad
and craig craig face no one said yo help
her he called them like yo do y'all need
would y'all like me to check this like
that's my bait like you know what i'm
saying you could tell you love something
when you get up off the couch and be
like yo though because he got the dm and
they had craig yeah what the hell is
this look shout out to jay said what if
it brings story con but here's the thing
like
the cadence is too long but this game
has so many problems we're talking about
forget forget xbox right now on pc
there's desync issues there's literally
issues core to the experience that are
affecting the game so you got to fix
that part right then they got the the
weird monetization pass with the
shoulders and the thing and that yeah
that's weird you know what i'm saying
they didn't launch with co-op they
launched with forge you know what i'm
saying
maps
like we when they stealth launch
maps exactly what being king said this
we wanted impression like oh they ready
ready because remember we was like yo
fours are doing just fine without you
being you didn't need them forza was
doing just fine like real talk you know
what i'm saying but we're like okay so
if you drop the bow top player you ready
you got things on deck and then after
that additional core gameplay and it was
fun and then the hype wore that and
people realized the same maps are the
same content it's as fun as it was
all and then live service game they're
not loyal if you're not doing nothing if
you're not fixing issues they out of
here destiny learned that the hard way
when division came outside and they took
their base and a lot of that and that's
one thing yeah but i gotta say apex
legend does
warzone does and definitely fortnite yes
the level of content that they pour
inside to these titles and updates and
fixes and maps and all this other stuff
not talking about forge not talking
about the co-op i'm talking about the
the the actual multiplayer game as a
service
it's not treated with the level of it's
like
they said yeah i could freestyle i could
i can i can i can spit drug drill music
too
and if you if you're not
familiar with it yet you think you can
do it actual practice in it actual
getting it done yeah
dude you wasn't ready he wasn't ready so
so what it all i can assume
is that i'll be honest of like
you rush just to get it across the
finish line yeah
hey you really didn't have i could only
assume
oh okay i'm still muted i'm muted
oh sorry oh okay
i'm sorry
yo how you doing when i was saying that
because the hell's angels are wilding
out back oh yeah
wow
but i look at halo infinite now and i'm
like yo this feels like it should have
been a game it comes out at the end of
this generation before because
none of it is ready none of it is ready
to the level you would expect from halo
and as much as we enjoyed like i said
once i saw the game play i was like i
i enjoyed this the back to basics i got
over the graphic stuff or whatever but
at the end of the day when you look at
the successful games in this space
it's one game you need to give it you
need to give it that amount of
dedication you need to give it epic all
they do is dgs and four
but here's the thing that's so
frustrating i hate to keep beating up on
them it's just like
this is halo
we fell in love with the brand for yeah
how is this not getting treated with the
reverence the respect the time like what
happened you know what i mean i'm i'm
i'm very thankful that staten is there
i'm thankful that we're trying to turn
this around and i do think they will
turn around the problem comes down to
you had a moment where the world was
yours
in that november what i'm saying the
world was you had everybody back playing
saying the king is back you know what
i'm saying
and this happens and they found out the
emperor had no clothes
[Laughter]
no no i everything you said i completely
agree with it is that thing of just like
it really like it feels like they they
to me if you look at the if you look at
the vision right everything they want to
do to switch it up and bring it forward
and bring people in
making it a game to the service was
perfect all of that stuff
making the actual campaign something
that's fluid that you can add to
and and making even the campaign parts
kind of a game as a service you expect
more story stuff right and making
calling it halo infinite i'm like
the vision is there yeah but they didn't
uh it feels like they didn't understand
that the execution required to pull that
off in this environment now is a lot
more than
we're gonna put a hundred million into
this game and that's gonna be the
product and we're gonna give you some
some some we're going to give you some
battle passes and some seasons and
that's it when you have the uh the other
the blueprints are out there for how to
make this work and it just feels like
they just either
and obviously it's not a resources thing
or it's not a resources that are being
allocated to this type to this game
thing but i feel like like i said like
dude
fortnight
whatever and now mind you fortnite is a
self-sufficient thing now right right it
pays it pays for the money that goes
into it
but i i think you know if if you if
microsoft really wants uh if xbox really
wants halo to be a thing in this way the
amount of money and and talent you have
to throw at it to keep it thriving and
alive is considerably more than what
they're doing right now yeah it goes
that way
i think halo like
as far as like the individual and now
it's coming to hello i don't want to
hear none of that [ __ ] that stuff
anymore i i've just gotten to the point
where it's like unless you're giving me
updates on game on the game itself like
content don't tell me who's joining
don't tell me what this don't tell me
that don't enjoy hearing about it
because i'm tired of hearing updates
that's not regarding the game it's like
we're past all that like we want to see
change we don't want to see anything
else anymore like this is a prime
example of
these companies and this and this is a
xbox that they decided and i've always
felt like halo could work for a free to
play model for against as a service
model
but people actually have to do stuff
with the game
and i feel like people want the destiny
back but people wouldn't want to work
destiny like correct
it it's just like look like they they
thought they were going to come out
there with some some half type content
and captivate all these people and they
got kicked back down to the first round
so it was just like they might have
literally sacrificed their biggest brand
to try to catch the destiny they catch
the destiny and the thing is i will say
this though it does feel like people who
play these type of games and are really
invested in these service games are
always love the comeback right they
really do they're always willing to come
back and and give it a shot if they if
it looks like they're doing what they're
supposed to right the true the truth
it's been true of destiny
fortnight's never really had that drop
or anything like that but it's been true
of games of this ilk that you know you
can piss off your fan base but if you do
them you know if you change things up
and do what they want you to do they'll
come back so
again you know addict doesn't want to
hear about the hirings but i think the
hirings overall
indicate that they're listening yeah
whether it's going to give you what you
want in a timely fashion that makes
sense for bringing people back and
having people actually care who knows
i don't know man only thing i want to
hear from bungie from 343 right now is
we got this new content for you let me
get that
before we move on um and i had this
discussion this is something maddie
brought to me on defining duke and i i
never got a chance to talk to y'all so
he's at the point of frustration right
so he's like yo
maybe it's time
and i was like what you mean he's like
kill it no no he's like maybe it's time
to let somebody else dry the wheel
and i don't want to go i gotta answer
but i don't before i answer i don't have
to talk because i say i want to get
let's just go let's go to your attic
first you know
like
is it is it to that part now are we
there
is there enough evidence
to convict
to say
that maybe there's a there's time for a
new direction
or nobody else at xbox game studios
y'all gonna like no no maybe
if you want to go to the campaign here's
the thing
halo was the only game
that's in the market right now for the
most part that people expect a solid
multiplayer and a solid single player
they don't expect one or the other they
expect both but then when you throw
these games as a service on top of all
that 343 is the only studio capable of
doing both of those at the moment for
halo
it's just
the cop
has got to go
the whole match we've got to get rid of
the counterpart they will say is that um
yeah with like live the live server spot
maybe it's because the live service
bottle was just too much the live
service works though it's just they're
not doing it well
and at that point you have a chance
yeah what's going on
what is going on i'm sorry we've just
gotten to the point where
we just got to the point right now where
it's on bonnie ross it's on phil spencer
these are the heads that need to be
flopping out when it comes yeah
even if it's solely bonnie ross and some
of the people under her
phil spitzer leads that project well
technically matt booty leaves it okay
first okay who who matt booty reports to
phil spencer
you're going up the ladder okay you're
going all the way it's just like look
like i don't think they should get rid
of phil spencer like this isn't
technically his fault but it's happening
on his then why he mentioned his name
because it's happening
like that
we're gonna go all the way up to the top
and then you're gonna say it's
technically ain't his fault don't walk
no
it's been long enough
it's been long enough to let you do your
thing i'll let you spin it and slide it
all over
wow but when something happens at sony
don't we don't we go straight to jim i
don't think that's the only face we got
like dudes don't tell who's doing what
over there so the only dude we got is
jim it's jim and the dude cerny who
messed up
because everybody else that had a face
and had a name is in a dungeon someplace
that we can't find so we're not even
gonna do that to them let's leave listen
no you ain't gonna do that today
so you reach for the top and then you
felt the heat the heat and was like no
no i really know because because
that's not putting people in
on his accountability all right all
right
did peter moore let halo get looked like
a laughingstock yeah peter boy ain't
dead
but did he but he said he said okay he
said that couldn't get he couldn't get
away either but listen so is it is it a
situation that we give at the top way
too much credit and way too much um
ridicule when something go wrong i'm not
oh you gotta ask my shade on oh
that's fine like i'm gonna do this
i would put the majority of this fault
on 343's management okay and then some
of it got to go to my booty and phil
because they let this you know what i
gotta say i'm blaming the squarely on
the shoulders of kovac oh
games of service halo infinite this that
in the third
now
the hardest part is launching the game
in this covet environment so why not
why not the lady game
i say this right first of all i enjoyed
the single player
so this is what
it was do you enjoy it now without co-op
okay cause i told dudes they was like
well i don't got fours i said i don't
care about you yes we know
it affects me
right so now it's it is affecting me
right now because battlefield is mopping
them in the streets
so now now it's like yo you're my man
you came out here with only one gun and
dude the outfit i just
like bonnie ross got to have the
cushiest job in the world she never gets
accountability for anything that goes on
at 3-4-3
but but she had three games and she
dropped the ball three times i i didn't
have
i really honestly believe this right
here all right switching it to a games
of a service
doing it now all right um trying to get
content out
i think they misjudged it just misjudged
the amount of work it takes in addict's
defense
let me get these balls i got you at it
let me we're not gonna act
like halo master chief collection is not
on a resume
that is one of the single most
disastrous launches in the history of
gaming of a major franchise i've ever
seen the game functionally did not even
work
i knew people who were willing to buy
that were playstation fans that had
their their hopes set on that game
because the concept was so fire to have
every halo game launched in this thing
and remember they used to do multiplayer
multiplayer and remember solve they had
the switch where you go for the
traditional graphics
to the new graphics
1080p60 this was one of the most
ambitious things i've ever seen and that
launcher not only did it launch broken
it took a long time for them to fix it
now to their credit they stuck with it
year after year after year and trying to
fix it but that was a long time i've
never seen a game launched like all
right so are we at the point right now
because i brought the chainsaw out for
you oh
right i got my vote but it's my turn but
i wouldn't know what your vote is
i said it before okay
i love her to death yeah
you you love you yeah you like body
pressure yeah i think i think
you know when you're sitting there
you're playing poker and they're dealing
the cards yeah
you got to play the hand that you got
and you can only bluff for so long oh
you know if you don't have a winning
hand they need to steal some cards they
need to do something man yeah but i
don't think she has the cards to be
played and i think they surround you a
multi-trillion dollar company don't have
the cards to be played come on i think
she doesn't have the cards to be played
not the trillion dollar company
i'm talking but she's in charge of one
of their most iconic brands listen
you're moving around mm-hmm
you keep it scented you said
her being a lead
this is the hard situation the cards
that's in her hands i don't think she
can out d she can get out of this
situation and maybe what you're saying
is right maybe
at this point in time she might have to
just you know take a step down and
disappear from that situation but i
think that is more detrimental
visually
if she was to so i think that's why
they're not until the ship is right
she won't and i think she'll be here
i don't even i don't even care if they
keep bonnie ross on just
let her be over there doing the social
media stuff like like the stuff i i
personally hold her responsible for the
tv show let her mess that stuff up keep
your hands off the game at this point
like let her do all
once you're a lifer of microsoft i
highly doubt don't ever get rid of it
but it's just like let jose stayton do
solely be responsible for the xbox stuff
and let him report to her about what's
going on but i don't want her
because clearly she
i was gonna say this one down i know i'm
interrupted i'm interrupting you i
apologize
um
what if what you're saying is actually
happening what if the announcement that
you wrote that you didn't like
is them
i'm just i'm guessing i don't know
anything right let's just say that this
is the slow transfer of power
yeah and maybe statin is getting more in
the building would that appease you
yes it would and i don't even like i to
my
knowledge that's not what's going on
here um you know but it could be the
these hirings and stuff that could be
stating getting rid of the bad fruit i i
don't know what's going on but it's just
like look i ain't trying to
to ask for someone's head on a platter
but it's just like oh i sound like three
games
i'm about i'm about consistency i feel
it if you show me three games back to
back where you're dropping the ball
seriously on one matter to another
like i feel like if she hasn't been a
lifer from microsoft she would have been
replaced by now
but it's just like you
and then you show us halo infinite and
we're months upon launch and we still
don't have any relative content
that has more to do with covet as far as
i agree with you i agree with you but at
the same time
stuff you know
listen addict i have no words to be
honest with you and i agree with your
frustration wholeheartedly i'm not going
to sit here and yell out that i'm the
greatest uh halo uh multiplayer dude i
jumped in and i played i got i got halo
for what i wanted for a single player
campaign and i'm in and i'm out there's
a lot of people that did that right and
they come back for whatever when when
they do get stuff up and ready
what i'm saying is i i'm with you 100
i don't think they can release her now
yeah i don't think they can honestly i
don't think something
yeah the optics will be crazy
but also to to cogs point
bringing in the help that they're doing
and the slow transfer of power like that
that's a good thing but also to addict's
point i don't wanna hear it yeah that
nobody wanna hear give me forge give me
the co-op give me what you promised me
and stop giving me the the hey well
today we hired bill from accounting and
said what is matt booty doing he should
be responsible as head of xbox studios
no no i i i said he did not work too and
so was phil but at the end of the day we
talking about three four three he should
be doing his job to maintain that studio
at the end of the day it's 343 that's
see the first thing the attic said was
there's no team built better today for
halo
and that's the truth like this is a team
building people making this game right
like like saw people saying id
has anyone played any multiplayer game
by id
like it's software i meant it's software
and then people saying the people that
make wolfenstein i could see them making
like a single player for halo but they
don't even make multiplayer and this is
the thing right and i'm i'll be the
first to tell you to blow everything up
and start over fine
yeah you you know
you're known for changing the direction
of a studio so
but i will say this
i think he said nobody else is built to
make the halo that people want more than
three four three
because the thing is remember they were
they they went another direction
everybody was like no we don't want this
halo 4.
they were they were parts of halo 4 that
people liked parts they didn't five same
thing yeah so i've always said this i'm
like they can make good halo they
haven't put it all together yet right
so now
the the the community told them no we
don't want that version to halo give us
old halo and they give you old halo
and and so they
from what the community wants from halo
they're the ones that are able to give
it to you they're not giving you enough
of it period right when you start
talking about other
uh you know other teams doing this you
look at ed like it is doom like do me
halo if if it makes that game are you
giving them the leeway to make the halo
game they want to make or they have to
make the halo game we're going to play
that's expected the crazy part saul is
people want to play hot potato of halo
instead of making the people making halo
better better and and that is that
that's the whole thing like did nobody
else look it i would look in a halo
offshoot like i said i'm the first one
to be like blow it up so
yes we know but but
if if you're going to appease the people
that love halo there are millions of us
um the vast majority want that old
experience and it doesn't make sense to
bring in a new team to try to pin and
hold them into that so for the record
let's do it now let's do it now
solve your vote three four three
straight remains or halo
3 remains you need to
what you need to do is say hey
we're not giving this the type of game
we've turned halo into requires a lot
more on a daily basis on a monthly basis
it needs just more all right cool one
for three foot three today kig
343 revision halo you're you're you're
you're a phil dominic spencer
i'm the maddie question does 343 remain
on halo under your watch
i'm phil yes
you're the dominance it's dominance
decision now
dang man you wild crazy dominance you
got it if i get rid of three four skin
tone change
[Laughter]
it would be what sovereign said it's
three four three states it's either
dynamite
or oh
you had the chase or you had to chase or
you pray it was close to reverend yeah
but it was full person
so so three so so you said three four
three stages of shake up in total
i i've what we do i think they need to
remove certain people from the situation
but if you remove sir people that they
might not be three four three three then
you talk about three four three so well
clearly three four three and we want it
to be either i gotta say i gotta sit
there with solve all right two for steak
okay three four three stage
addict three four three you are
addict dominant spencer
this is it's on your it's on your watch
getting his color back
it's like phil spence is doing a
character customization for a game right
now they just switch it back and forth
between yeah he put you back in barack
was it the blade point okay
barack
it does do you make the decision as the
head of xbox to keep 343 or halo
infinite halo a franchise
hey it comes down to it i think 343 is
the only student
but it's just like look neither bonnie
ross gets that studio up where it needs
to be or people need to be replaced in
masses like look i i get it covered
probably threw that whole studio through
a loop but it's just like you for
something like covid microsoft just take
the l and delay it again
that's what they realistically should
have done we can't that that's a future
that will never happen but it's just
like they're hurting their brand more by
releasing it last year than they are
then so they remain but you need major
change internally yeah i need to see
major changes i don't know if that's a
bonnie ross being getting up out of
there i don't know if that is some of
the management getting up out of there
but i need to see change all right so
you want to dissolve so you want them to
show you the bill they got to show you
they build or the consistent basis to
see they got to show me something
because what i've been seeing ain't it
all right so we're unanimous by the same
uh as much
i'm very angry with that look if 343
doesn't make halo halo needs to be
almost i'm very and the reason why i'm
angry with them is because i feel if i
hate to say this if it wasn't for them
we wouldn't hear this mismanagement talk
so much but because we have a little
problem child in the building you know
them in the initiative whatever
i give anybody who ain't produce a game
yet a slight pass yet because you got to
produce a game but it was full of a
bunch of five-star producers
my thing is that's just me i understand
for people who still say that's [ __ ]
but great that's their opinion i'm not
denying it i'm just saying for me
personally i don't judge until you put
out at least one product and then i can
say okay this is how you did you know
i'm saying under the watch but for me
i i'm gonna say 343 keeps it but
what i need to see
is one i feel the same as king and it's
all like
staten needs to he needs to be like give
him the keys give him because if he was
able to at least get the delay to the
one year and get the story in a
serviceable spot and we all agree the
gameplay the multi-player is fire we all
agree right it just said he had no
content right i mean i i feel like the
game will be fine for the most part once
forge comes out because the community is
going to take what they should be doing
but it's just like
it it's just crazy that the how well
that game was received at launch until
now like they have the perfect
foundation yes they just
build the house build the house get the
house built get this man that's why i
love this hire this hire shows that they
know they recognize they cannot meet
their deliverables in a fashion between
the design team and the engineering team
whatever the teams that need to
collaborate and this guy seems to be a
specialist at that do that come back
with a full package they need a taken
king moment
they need this is a complete revamp on
pve pvp here's maps here's forge here's
co-op here's new content here's the
chief of the new story we fighting
against the endless whatever it is you
know what i'm saying and it's on and you
rebrand it you can come back one thing
about live service if you do it right
you can come back but i feel you give
state the keys you do what you got to do
and i give them a shot at it whatever i
mean maybe that battle royale will bring
you in the battle royale right and my
last thing though if they don't do it
i need to see
repercussions because the the the the
attack
on them
is the beautiful thing about microsoft
is this hands-off thing let them do what
they do let them know what they're doing
when do you think it's a good exact time
frame
to have those repercussions we're almost
a year into the uh into release now it's
a good point i i can't dispute you and
anybody three anybody who says they
gotta go
i'm gonna let you go that cake all right
i don't know i i i i know something oh
okay okay no i'm gonna say anybody who
said they gotta go i can't really argue
i can't fight i can't dispute addict
there's nothing i can say to make you
say no they deserve to keep i can't so
but i i do agree
you you keep in any profession if you
keep missing deliverables and you keep
having problems
that's how i would go that's just the
game you know i'm saying i'm not trying
to be evil i'm not trying to call nobody
else specifically this is a hard
business but there has to be re-because
you can't have one person in the house
you got you got listen you got turn 10
out here doing anything with the forza
motorsport franchise you got you know
what i'm saying the coalition with the
gears franchise you got playground games
outside dude you got obsidian who knew
who dropping mad games and grounded and
out of worlds and potentially they
dropping content you know what i'm
saying you got people in the building
doing their thing
one got to be held accountable if they
don't so i hope this is the
accountability that we're seeing now
with the highest and that's it but can't
get you thinking then we go
i think
right now
343 is still there doing what they're
supposed to do right now
only because they don't have any content
when 2023 roll around and these games
start coming out and they start hitting
metacritic 80s high 80s and 90s or
whatever and they start coming to
consistency
that's when they're gonna really look
over at the redheaded step kid and say
y'all yeah
your sales ain't been good
the numbers ain't been right that's when
you can call it to the office but right
now okay
they have delivered product
so they have measurables and they're in
the streets and they have a chance to
fix it if they don't fix that product
by the time that the other dudes start
rolling yeah and they have a good they
have a they have see see right now
microsoft is unsure
right because there's no product but
this is the only dude that had it
now if they have
ample product coming out mm-hmm that's
when they can look over and start
reprimanding people
and i think that's when it's gonna
happen when a vowel in this joint
when they call your neighbor the
loudspeaker
they'll tell you
[Music]
because
of the pandemic you do have to naturally
give them a little bit more time to
catch up but
it's just like my thing is
what is a good time frame i don't know
how devastating the pandemic was
i would say
i would say
2022 and 2023 if we start 2024 and we're
nowhere near close to seeing they don't
they don't have no content at the next
ep they are no show
yeah i think i think they'll have
content but here's the thing
what type of content is it like because
that matters next year they're like yo
the co-op is and i think ford's will
help them a lot but it's just like
i i do personally feel like look like by
the e3 of next year because i think
that's a good time frame
you got to have something like something
drastic too like the like the the
the battle royale
gotta be good
fire fight all that make all the modes
swat or i'm with you look and then if if
if they ain't hitting then then you know
maybe people's heads need to roll like
look 343 we voted you on the island we
had an objective fair talk we voted you
on an island but next year or else that
seems to be the consistency
yeah that's that's all right cool let's
move on
yeah i got the cat i didn't do that yeah
i bought the guy it was kind of funny it
was annoying because people people were
clowning people to buy it so i had to
buy it just to get it i like getting
killed with the dudes with k is that
going for it got me money yeah that was
that was not the most about that
hold on a second let me uh let me roll
back a little bit okay that's again we
got some uh some strong opinions here
you don't know taco two dollar super
chat y'all missed the week it's your
fault
sorry sorry this is taking a vacation
for doing a podcast since 2017. how dare
i not take a week off
almost 700 yeah hit that like button
subscribe to the channel save the
children
children let's do that subscribe you
subscribe you save a puppy
and get king closer to his crack deal
oh buddy crocs want to see the
subscribers so if y'all want to make it
make it happen yeah yeah more crocs
i'll be right back you got two you got
you got two um moving over there you got
it too
oh yeah let me move that off the door
this year because we just have a
dominance talk that's right
yeah we got flames
two dollar super chat
i don't have to be nice scrap 343 not
cute anymore yeah like i said strong
opinions
jesus here we got lucious augustus
member for 11 months
after the juneteenth bona bowl situation
i haven't really touched halo infinite
343 got to do more to get me back season
two is whack yeah a lot of people feel
strongly about that i get it
yeah i didn't purchase yeah
what away dragons tv five dollars up a
chat
destiny one and two has been through
this rainbow six siege battlefield
fortnight and look what they turned out
today patience to all facts yeah i mean
i can feel that but at the same time
shouldn't they have learned from those
other people that's exactly my feeling
it's like those people were those people
were like the the first people to really
hit that market hard
so like to me i feel like
you shouldn't have to have those hiccups
that they had and i don't know what it
takes to make this halo infinite uh you
know games as a service thing but it's
just like i do personally feel like
between covid and some maternal problems
that is what led to this yeah yeah and
all we want is accountability we do yeah
and i just feel it's unfair that the
rest of the studios are catching smoke
because of one studio public flogging
yeah
yeah spanking
statement to be honest with you
for hardcore halo fans they deserve
something like that at this point this
is halo they've worked for
just like you're going to have god of
war on
november the 9th
stealing bones my
we need to get off halo it's been eight
months all the apex and co have had had
bad starts again back to the point you
saw what they did content is can you
knew this content is king
that's it and we we can't act like hey
look it's a small studio like they got
like 100 people
they got massive amount of people i
think that makes it worse yes i agree it
does to a point it does make it a lot
harder to communicate with each other
on a grand scale and especially during
like like the pandemic like having more
people it actually hurts you than having
less people but having more people does
help you produce content like how many
how many people does that the bungie at
like a lot like hog
can attest to this
managing people oh yeah while they in
their comforts of their home
and they can get up and walk through the
refrigerator and do whatever yeah yeah
i'm working i'm working and remember
solve that article i think it was try
okay when we were actually giving halo
infinite praise at launch he said how
the development they were all of these
little separate teams of fife wasn't no
one it's yeah the contractor thing
remember the 18 month rule and you got a
cycle out it's a lot of stuff i'm not
gonna sit there and say they had stuff
but it's just like nobody don't want to
hear it so it's like
that too man
release two expansions in this pandemic
yeah absolutely
tough love uh let me see it's a tough
one we have tyson buhajo uh eight dollar
super chat bobby kotec gets the heat
from looking the other way on toxic
culture phil spencer should get some
heat from watching 343 fail and not
change anything watch your mouth
at your mouth
i guess you knew here
[Laughter]
and i'm going to tell you something very
clear watch your mind
there's no there's no are you implied
there's no dominance
slander because you will get this
[Music]
i wasn't paying attention to the day man
yeah you
feel more than welcome to super chat
stuff
shout out to you
i'm just telling you watch your mouth
that's clearly on kingsman will be no
phil spencer
here
i don't know what podcast you came from
but over here
he don't
listen listen
watch your mouth
phyllis beloved clearly my kid here
after the lords and king has sent a tone
about the person who disrespected us
so clearly
you got the goons on deck be careful i
want to make sure you have a good time
hey we got somebody rowdy and now four
clean up in our fall
i can't put the diamonds
watch
[Laughter]
too much people pleasing from microsoft
how did halo go from leading to
following microsoft does too much
reacting and not enough acting
a strong kingdom
i like you
you ain't saying that about phil relax
i'm just saying this is borderline
[Laughter]
you guys want to give constructive
criticism i could do that in the in the
comforts of your own brain
you're not allowed to speak publicly
about it
i can't right now this is this we won't
be doing that today
i can't do it
then we got joe done more five dollars
with a chat halo is in the wrong hands
it's like giving your 16 year old the
keys to the escalade
all right then we got mr he might
surprise you
or he might wreck your car
i think the chances are worse than 50 50
though i know
there we got mr irish midfield possibly
chat i remember seeing a report that
microsoft mandated that halo had to come
out last year not xbox not 343 it was
microsoft 343 was dealt a bad check
writer the check writer you yeah the
check writer spoke it was on the back of
the box
let me tell you something we had taco
bell deals
yeah we have pop-tarts but shout out to
staton that had enough power in the
building to say no
we're not doing this and we got that's
power that's why i'm rocking with state
man hopefully
we fixed craig's face yeah he should
have done it again
we got splendid difference but for nine
months we got to be like sony and say
whatever studio didn't have a hit this
year you are now a support studio
damn support studio status damn
you understand [ __ ] this is the this is
where we are
these dudes want
oh we want hands off we want we want
they have a great environment we want
them to be just like sony if you ain't
getting a hit
you got to kill them yeah no
it's a tough balance it's a tough
balancing very tough balance and the end
of that
keep keep all your butts cats will hit
the bushes and that's it
then we got hearty city 10 000 the
second halo could it be released with
co-op knew it needed to be delayed heard
from so many people three months always
said no way lucky to get it summer
likely fall 22 should have been delayed
okay okay i think we still got one more
yeah we got a couple more we got the uh
game crash anybody single player
no right yeah
that's right yeah
i played the campaign just fine
i can't pay you work right now it wasn't
great but you know
the wise old gave her five dollars don't
worry i've just solved everyone's
problems with halo i just sent bonnie
ross my member pick whoa whoa we don't
do that over here
he's like hey it worked with santa
monica jesus
oh man oh
man man we've seen you in the wild
yes i understand he was doing a five to
six
stop sending pics you're not supposed to
be next to a pc yo
i can't
good
yeah
10 super chat halo infinite will be
complete by the end of the year with
co-op and forge they just need more
support t-10 and tc went back to their
own game so they don't have the backup
anymore
we got jd gamer 10 chat e3 plus read pop
equals amazing coming up next what i
campaigned for which was many of us
asked for and it's what jeff was afraid
of and that's why he immediately reacted
to it but it's too late for that e3 for
the win okay okay
about
momentarily get jeff no we got hearty to
would be that
need once again five dollars which i
suppose if you look at sony and what put
them on the map are those games still
around for nintendo it still is mario
zelda just interesting i mean yeah if
you look at what put sony on the map
well put something on the map was weird
stuff like ps1
it's man yeah
there's a lot of weird stuff there great
uh let me see what else i think i gotta
jump
people don't realize what put sony on
the clutch man is next okay
they were they were
so brash
aggressive oh yeah
that's what put them on the mat that's
how we got gran turismo
king i always got my crocs on you
already no
why are you prepping them for that man
though
i like you you got to relax
[Laughter]
throw them in the crocs you're declared
you do
[Laughter]
there you got jd gamer remember for 28
bucks thank you sir expect read pop to
do more after they successfully relaunch
e3 next year and after that expect them
to come for the crown as they launch an
awards show
yes please do so we can have some real
guidelines with real situations
there we have let me see your dog we got
clutch man two dollar super chat my bad
it's me who bought the white one
man yeah put that in the in the comments
on the checkout with y'all at the time
it's pinned at the top man make sure
y'all get y'all drip y'all swag and
ducky i'm just playing with you relax
there we go it's 80 game of ten dollars
in a chat read pop's industry-wide award
will be transparent and run by by
committees with clearly defined rules
and cut-off dates a stark contrast to
the sony game awards show we have with
jeff
e3 for the winners feeling jeff's
influence
that's a buddy film uh award show
wow
that's crazy
then we got mandingo mc thicket oh five
dollar super chat dance move ryan's wife
after session with mcthickens three
quarter people be all right halo has an
outstanding foundation just finished the
building wow
what are you doing to us
and we got spartan go 17. five pound
super chat jason schreier is still
crying about microsoft activision
blizzard deal e3 coming back jeff in
tears boris johnson out is this the best
timeline
hilarious i'm done oh we caught up
let me see you know how they like to
jump i think we're good i think we're
caught up all right this is addict's
topic i set him up um yeah i'm here okay
cool i'll just set you up
you can set me up though you can set me
up
this week pax organizer read pop to run
e3 2023
and they're working with the esa to
bring back that trade show the long
string trade show in june and we have a
statement from um the esa president and
ceo stanley pierre-louis we are thrilled
to bring back e3 as an in-person event
with read pop a global leader producing
pop culture and votes events the past
three years have confirmed that e3
convenes or confirms the past oh this is
these are hold on i even catch these
these are silent jabs
the past three years
have confirmed justified jabs that e3
convenes our industry like no other
event yo i'd even catch that that was a
sad
brings world-class talent and a keen
understanding of the games games video
games industry which will serve to
enhance the e3 experience for years to
come read pop president lance fensterman
added it is a tremendous honor and
privilege for repop to take on the
responsibility of bringing e3 back in
2023 with the support and endorsement of
the esa we're going to build a
world-class event to serve the global
gaming industry in new and broader ways
than we already do at re-pop through our
portfolio of world leading events and
websites attic this is your topic
read pop pax leaders and creators
what do you feel about this
he's in the bushes and his camera's back
on why is his camera why is he sitting
here
what is he doing did he freeze no no i
didn't phrase that he was doing wildness
look
you know
i i have been saying it for a while e3
was coming back everyone said i i was uh
talk to him
it's i even think media people were
saying it's not coming back when i was
saying it was coming back
i remember being in parties with people
in the media sour no adding i think is
done look better like
regardless how you feel how they let
more public in which i feel like that's
uh that's uh what's all i'm looking for
that's an entitlement that you feel like
that you shouldn't share the floors with
common folks yeah uh
i do understand
that there needs to be a balance for e3
when you let people in yes but i but i'm
not going to say that they don't need to
let the calm and focus it
but king
i feel like look like because you know
like like the ryan mccaffreys
you know even us to a point like we need
to go to that for for for work for like
it's not just like some dude coming in
just wanting to play a game but so maybe
like make a whole day like extend the
expo by day and that's only media i feel
like if you can't get the majority of
your stuff done that you don't have
meetings for in a whole day then maybe
you shouldn't be covering this industry
in the first place
it's just like to me when it comes to
what's going on um you know i don't
personally feel like
um jeff has
has filled that spot for e3
uh i don't i don't have an issue with
this summer game show but i just it's
never really vibed with you like i felt
like the last this year was mid
last year was mid uh the year before
that was made like jeff stay over there
at the video game awards like
this tuesday stuff
it's just like i don't i don't think
that that's what we need like
i do feel like jeff has more access to
certain people that have left the
industry
but
that's why i feel like the esa has
parked it up
with uh
repo because repop has those those
those partnerships as well
and you know we we might look at it from
like you know the jeff versus versus e3
thing but imagine read pop repub was
come to their nemesis pretty much and
said yo run our stuff
hold on difference coming at you
he said we could put e3 and attic in the
bushes because he like it so much i like
my xbox vents a little better no batter
no matter how bad they are get them i
like my xbox what he said
xbox event's a little better no matter
how bad they are he likes better than
either um splendid i don't know if
that's like sarcasm coming from that uh
but when
when e3 was official um
king did we have an xbox event last year
yes sir
um when e3 was there the year before the
year before that king did we have an
xbox event that year uh i i truly
believe so yeah has ever been in e3 that
we didn't have an xbox event king uh uh
sir as long as they've been in existing
banking games i believe that we they've
been there
oh here we go
those are the ones that's not there i'm
sorry
so splendicers i i'm gonna have to ask
you to
get out of the bushes to put me in the
bushes all right uh-oh what's outside
now
i told you
don't come for us unless we send for you
so i mean you know i i think i think
it's a good move i think that uh you
know
i i personally feel like
e3 is essential like people sit there
and they see what they see on these
press conferences and the ign covers
where they walk the floor you're not
seeing what's going on in the back
you're not seeing what's going on
upstairs like those
is what's important and that's there's a
reason where they could go for a year
come back and everybody's with them
again
because they know that it's easier to to
do business with everybody in the same
house
and when people aren't in the same house
you got to fly people out there you got
you got to pay for for room board when
people are coming there for other
reasons it's easy to hit up iop and be
like yo we know you at e3 can we set up
a meeting like shot is on fire rozzo
gamer says she's a 10 but she still
believes summer games fest is a legit
substitute
that's pretty much like where i stand
with that i'm glad he threes back myself
because i feel like especially us
we've we've grown exponentially since we
last time we was at e3
so uh you know i'm i'm hoping that you
know we we can oh yeah we could have
some fun fun and get our ball yeah we
had our bones yeah fun fun
listen if they're coming back
it's read pop that needs to do it
because at the end of the day what you
realize about e3 and what it needs to be
moving forward and at least partially it
has to be
a truly fan centric event right
with the aspect with the aspect
separately
for
the press and i just i think you know
they can't come back and try to give you
the exact same thing in the exact same
rapper yeah without addressing the
issues right so for me when you look at
it e3 starts or whatever the friday
right
if you can get these big publishers back
you can get your sony back you get xbox
one you get all that stuff you i like
that format where everybody does their
press conference up front and the show
starts proper i think the first two days
monday and tuesday following the xbox
event on sunday should be press days
period
straight two days press everybody gets
all their meetings out of the way
everybody can see what needs to be doing
two days two days people are not doing
he's a 10 in the chat yeah
yeah they go
someone said he he's uh she's a 10 but
she oh you already read that yeah put
put some into 10 scenarios i want to
laugh while i eat
day one day two monday tuesday following
the xbox press conference press all
press we get in there we do what we got
to do we see what we need to see if we
want to stick around for wednesday
thursday friday that's fine if not it's
your prerogative to leave wednesday
thursday friday belongs to the fans and
at the end of the day and if you can
if you can do something because the
thing the big thing for these for these
exhibitors right for these companies is
that it's always costs an arm and a leg
to go to e3 and it's like why do we need
to pay you to do this when we can do it
ourselves right if you could find some
way to subsidize whatever these
exhibitors are paying for their show
floor space with whatever you're
charging the fans to come and see this
stuff
then i think
i think there's a there's a way but
again e3 for it to get to where it was
before microsoft got to be on board
playstation got to be on board nintendo
got to be on board if you don't have
your first parties in your actual
factual if you don't have your first
parties there
and and and to me
it is that thing of like i agree with
addict 100 i think jeff
jeff as the steward of all things gaming
in the summer only works
when he doesn't every like opening night
live okay what he did for what he did
for the you know your summer game fest
what he's gonna do for gamescom
those shows don't need that
that's not those shows are not the game
awards the game awards is where you have
all that it but if he wants to be the
steward of that stuff and get everybody
together into an event that doesn't
necessarily have him having this opening
night where he's forced to have to look
for announcements and stuff like that
that these companies could do themselves
right
i think
i think you have a little bit of a
competition there but if e3 comes back
proper and read pop does what it's known
for doing is we're creating great
fan-centric shows while acknowledging
the things that have to change about the
press side of it yeah i think it's i
think it's a goal
someone said alloy's attempt but she's
boring
they are they
i got a quick question for the for the
lords real quick and this goes in key
well let's say jeff jeff's obviously
going to the summer game he's not going
to bend the knee he he gonna come out
and try to spare me e3
if they both have in-person offense
which one we going to
i don't know
i mean i mean
they're probably they're going to be in
the same proximity that's for sure
now what happens if chad pulls up and he
gets xbox exclusively goes his show yeah
xbox ain't
[Music]
[Music]
he he was ahead of the curve
when he saw stuff happening it was just
a series of uh unfortunate events that
happened with e3 as far as leaking uh
pressed stuff out you know so once
people felt uncomfortable
with their security
he capitalized very good very good this
is what you're supposed to do you see
your opening you're supposed to take a
shot he's supposed to take his shot
you're supposed to go for your yeah for
sure for sure you know he has his goals
and i'm gonna tell you right now
his award shows is beautiful i love the
game
his stage everything his presentation
he has brought it fantastically i'm not
gonna lie isn't read pop the people that
do packs yeah they do packs not only do
they packs they do so but you they do a
lot pete i mean they d they do um
pax egx star wars celebration and your
new year comic comic con
so here here's the thing real quick
though king
if pax does pax is going to be you know
doing all the brunt work when it comes
to all the decision making it looks like
esa just going to be like the silent
parker kind of silence
so
this is the part
where i'm with
and this is the part where y'all can
call me a fraud oh oh oh i can call me
an elitist
you can call me you know what a rubber
standoffish you you can call me a
recluse you can call me a gauraphobe you
can call me uh uh uh a germaphobe you
can call me whatever you want to call me
i don't want you touching me
i got one thing to say to you king i got
one thing to say to you he attend but he
think e3 is only for media
and i i i don't i don't want it
i i want it how it used to be you know
oh get off my lawn
i'm that guy how many days do you need
exclusive media i need two days i need
two i need oxygen all right i don't want
to look over and and and
and and tim is is with his girlfriend
bianca and bianca don't really want to
be there but tim want to wait on the
line for zelda and he knows in the
four-hour wait but she didn't
and she's like why we got to be here i'm
standing up for tim because he don't
want to pop in the bag cut out so yeah
so in other words you don't want tim
going because they may go nobody you
know what you know what it is i want tim
to go mm-hmm i want tim to go have his
experience don't break her it's very
elite let's let's leave the plus ones at
home very elite talk
listen you know what no
for the leaders of fan celebration the
leaders of fan community
games
it's those guys
i see you all three days ago
dj oro said so basically i'm not invited
you went left because there are a lot of
females
that don't play games and they're there
because so what you're saying is you
just don't want non games
thank you please this is this is not
disney world get out of here
but what if this experience could turn
her turn this person into a game
go go go download i actually agree
keep them non-gamers at home wow
that elitist i agree with them wow
i don't care what stacy's passions are
okay
so what's the criteria they're gonna
have to take a gaming quiz
look if you play games like even if you
play if you play games passionately
about one game you invited you invited
them how were they supposed to make this
determination huh how is reedpop
supposed to know but here's the thing if
you be if you'd be like making tick
tocks on on tick tock with
about games and the controller always
off yeah
what i want is the two days for uh
the the press right yep
okay i we need the two that's a lot
that's how long no no
wednesday thursday friday for fans bro
all right let's be real come on we go to
cadence
sunday going to be that but microsoft
bethesda slash activated slash everybody
the acquired conference right right then
monday usually is that day space right
right tuesday through what thursday is
usually e3 on the floor so what you're
saying so what you're saying you want
monday and so after the conferences you
want to do to stay over two days they
flew out to l.a but they can't come to
the convention for two days well that
means they don't come to the throne
don't come till wednesday
the whole thing is you're basing it
you're basing on what it used to be it
can't be do you do
my thing my thing is like
and you and you and you're assuming and
you're assuming everybody's coming
across country like you know like oh my
god it'd be the most egregious ones is
the people that lived there
you know you know would be crazy like
when you're trying to get a flight and
you click the date and it says now are
you sure because their [ __ ] said on
wednesday
wow
you know what i truly don't like
this is what i truly don't well the hell
yeah that's a hard job
don't act like we wasn't out there don't
act like he was on
on the concrete floor of a mall trying
to hope to get inside some e3 and now we
got it
and we
you remember pax when you was wrong
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
you can buy me very easily like i've
no no listen you know why microsoft
decided to do the overnight and stuff
like that
for the fraud dudes that walked up it's
like what y'all doing here oh you're
staying down you're to go to a show
tomorrow it's a free show if i just stay
yeah don't do that had no business being
there then when he found out he had to
stay there overnight you saw the crowd
dispersed and only the true jesus stuck
around and the truth this is what i want
i'm down
i'm fighting for the two days
the reason why is our prep work our
concentration our time from going to
developer to developer and giving you a
concise uh interview and
background of their games one day is not
enough and and the level of how we work
i'm not talking about a lot of how these
other frauds work and they sit home and
they get their stuff mailed to them and
then they get their stuff and they they
write it up and then we're on the floor
all right so i feel you i feel like we
need we need that time and and they have
yo listen mm-hmm you know those halls
you gotta go
that lord's acting like the kardashians
i knew the crocs would change them
dj or heroes he got that croc croc money
and now we can't go to e3 no i want
y'all [ __ ]
thank you listen i want y'all there from
wednesday to saturday
yeah so how about this how about this
let's i'll take this i'll take this the
guys that are lucky anybody who's lucky
enough to win passes to the press
conferences you could come in day one
and two you know they got here
you're you're giving them the privilege
you're
gotta hit the lotto man
go hit the solve
go hit the slots
everybody think this is this is bad is
what i'm saying it's not usually the
down day is monday right
and then you have tuesday because they
do the show yeah down day's monday down
day is usually monday yes so you're
saying turn that down day and turn that
down i'm with you i'm there
on that day into into interview you know
heaven yes right we go we go do our
interviews we have schedules listen a
lot of times we're not the only we it's
not a lot i'm saying the only one's
there i get that
all i'm saying is all right so let's say
i could see
i could see the monday one day media i
could see that but tuesday y'all acting
like remember when you got that media
badge you look at that line you go to
the front of the line
and the
yeah the plebs don't get in because you
get it so you still
we got to call it what it is right so
also so we was plebs remember on long
lines and getting skipped by the blue
badge dude and the media dude when kanye
west bumped you out of there and i had
the whole that i had to rub it so you're
gonna have to hold it now right
[Music]
for the people i think this is the croc
gang and the other crew of the lords we
need
and we're really trying to separate our
community now yes we are
advocating for the channel and for the
website yes i know right clearly we need
the interviews because we are the ones
that's actually
us with a lot of other media somebody
said you use code by your lord elite
yeah what i don't want your shoulders
touching my shoulders while i'm trying
to get this
hours with dev that is not enough for
you no you don't have 24 hours how many
how do you go how many people go in
there with media credentials now like
you know you act like we're the only
ones all right so we can't make
appointments um
that says should media have two days
before common
[Laughter]
don't even give us two days
in the morning
you know king what's funny they're
acting like they're gonna be mad if they
give them two days
what you're saying
that if that did happen that we
out of being who we are we gonna be like
we staying home those two days what's
that yeah we ain't we able to go with it
and it's like there's no presence let me
skip here uh shout out to abcaf72
remember for 18 months this is how they
do it at gamescom in tokyo game show
first two days of media only and the
race of the week is open to the public
somebody got some sense
i love how you skipped protocol to
readers that go ahead with it
oh
we've been doing this for like five six
years there is a point where when you
make it you don't want to share with
people that that haven't grinded like
that yeah but i do think there's got to
be a middle ground like we can't just
just because yeah we can't just be like
you know how in rts is when i don't want
them to come over the bridge i raise the
bridge up that's what you guys want to
check this out though right you don't
you you have this situation now right if
you're a dude who's not media and you're
on a line
and you get skipped by a media dude
you're gonna be pissed this eliminates
that because now you have your own line
and now now now reverse is true
reverse is true if your media and you
don't get yourself done in the first two
days you don't get preference wednesday
through friday right you got to wait on
the line if you want to talk to the deaf
period no
like
when you go to e3 you do got your own
little like it's like packs you have
your own little schedule things that you
see behind closed doors like people
acting like they waiting in these lines
none of these people are waiting in
these lines like these media people have
scheduled meetings
yo
remember how we you had to schedule um
spencer's uh revenge explanations
yeah
yeah i remember that remember we were
supposed to do the four players yes
they shut us down
why they shut us down because because
the fans came first
oh so you say okay i see we had this not
been had they said we instead of that
one little funky hour
that they gave people right and listen
to you guys i'm with you there and and
everybody in the chat should support my
argument because
we're actually out there getting you
content yeah absolutely i'm not going
there to to play games
i'm going to be a hundred yeah we're
going to cover them
shouldn't that actually technically work
against your argument because no listen
let me finish
pop
right
if they actually gave us one day and i'm
just talking about three packs packs pax
is on because they're shorter than e3 e3
is a week-long event right
yeah you got a point right but pax is
shorter if you gave us one day
the hours in between is is crazy
uploading dropping information
coordinating with you act like we got a
media room though no we do
they're gonna act like they give us
something that we stay up in the media
room after we go get the interview
because we have to upload it because we
live in a now situation we want to get
the content to the to our fan base to
our friends our family to everybody that
needs it right then yo we saw splinters
we this is how it's going check it out
we weren't able to get content because
of that barrier because they were too
busy worrying about the fan base and
worrying about pleasing the crowd right
we were not able to give you absolutely
the four-player co-op tradition that we
always do
right
you know who's got that
when i want to send it to the house so
how do you don't reward
the media that's actually foot boots on
the ground mm-hmm there i get that we're
not going to come out we are in
agreement
i know we got some very uh talented
people in the chat i want you to find
some kind of video
where it's showing king raising a bridge
with all the common folks on the other
side
listen to that like
i'm not saying that what i'm remembering
media needs their days
and i'm going to tell you this
too that will make e3
back again
because better for everyone you still
have your wednesday to your saturday
listen listen you still have your
wednesday to your saturday that
everybody is in
checking out games they want to play
games they want to do this they don't
have to worry about worrying about
interviews and stuff like that you can
just cater to the crowds that's exactly
right
so if somebody walks past uh the
the the stadium and says oh man what's
going on over there oh you can get a
badge uh and you can buy a badge for 125
and go inside and see what's going on
i'm cool with that and they can go in
there and they can have a great time
media already did they work for the week
and that stuff is already uploaded
somebody said kick build building walls
make e3
you know what it is
i can see king with like this this look
and he's looking out and he sit there
and you see all these people running for
the gate they're all running for the
game they call it the is ours
listen
me and solve is the only one yeah right
yeah
y'all in the chat y'all gonna be so
happy when y'all online waiting to play
whatever the hotness is hey
and king and i
would stroll up and they'd be like yeah
you know oh now you're gonna have to
wait
rather than on wednesday it's all for
you it's all for you y'all
[Applause]
[Applause]
salute
i just feel like that's not realistic
but if they get it they get they give us
you said something else all right we
just say two different names we're
saying the same concept but i don't
think two days is realistic i said a day
you'll take it if they offered it but
you think you know
is it not realistic when you have two
other times that it's being filled
your justification is is the size of of
the convention hall yeah everybody else
around the world is doing it
you act like iop and and lords of gary
has a hundred steps
if we really want to be able to compete
with the igns and the bigger
right the ones that really do get like
yeah
then we needed that
you acted like we have those eggs
behind the scene with the dev
environment that be off the floor let's
be clear when you go to e3 you acting
like us as the media gonna be going
around like the comments
remember we go up that second escalator
to that whole floor where the dude the
vip dude with the guns that be around
they'd be like oh excuse me sir what
your bad focus
yeah the dudes that was around reggie
felix and may and phil and then we go to
a whole new area that's all separate and
we'd be in there and they come in they
got the food and the drink and the setup
and the candy
that was crazy
but you know it's true you know what's
crazy
in the past they'd be acting like we've
waited two hours for every show
that's what i've got to say we don't
wait it'll be like
hey mister
here's your appointment
hi
would you like a drink with that song
thank you for coming to take your time
for covering our game you know
you know what it is so
he
is the one in the elevator he
is the one upstairs
you ain't talking get it this is the
same
i do want to point out that i have never
been to e3 as media no you was going to
know we was today we was with the devs
that did the um i brought you in there
don't worry about it
i've never had a media listen
it was the evil geniuses what was it
what was that game
it was even it was
about
did you have a media pass that year i
have immediate pass every year what's up
shut up
this is the same man that we had to walk
past him and there was a velvet rope
between us and he was over there with
colt eastwood he was over there with all
these
[Applause]
bro we struggle don't forget this
this is the thing we're forgetting right
all the things you mentioned it is oe3
yes that his show is not going to work
anymore right
you're talking about it from a new e3
perspective of a company that's never
done anything remotely close to that
right but everything they've done is fan
centric meaning
meaning they have to find that middle
ground yeah what happens if they go a
completely different way this is awesome
solve it
and there's yours
meat is not even inviting
oh
i am assuming that it's traditional esa
format right that's what i'm talking
about but there is a channel
right if read pop takes over and makes
it a pax like experience it would be
more community focused and less of the
uh of the media exclusive so i'll give
something and if that happens then i
gotta go with jeff
how quick king just turned yeah he
turned things around quick bro if they
don't want to play ball hey jeff
i didn't think this is gonna pop off
like this but oh look you know it it's
it's interesting all i'm gonna say is
look i do think it's back it's good to
see
re-popped
we going you know it should be a
fantastic year xbox should be in full
shred with 2023's lineup you know
they're going to bring back fan fest
beverly hills that's going to be lit you
know what i'm saying
um what i will say though
i would like to see if
the block between sony
gets lifted because remember the
self-imposed block soldier said we ain't
coming right
if repop now involved to sony say yo i
don't think they wasn't on my side i
don't know i don't know i don't think
they're coming nintendo we assume we
should come back though right yeah
if sony comes back because there are
issues with the usa and reef pop is
running it yeah i think look this is the
best possible scenario as opposed to the
e3 being dead right and we have to admit
like patrick's got to get it right i'm
with y'all though there has to be a
balance a proper balance between media
and fan though i'm with y'all on that
part um i think they definitely need to
protect the media's data because we yeah
in the middle with at least one day of
appointments i'll take one day at me and
minimum you know i don't know if we get
the two i'm not refusing but i'm just
just saying but um i'll take two if they
give it to you of course why would i
know
no one is sane
i would go to e3
because you just don't think you're
gonna get it yeah
i'll just have to start dj orals gaming
to start writing
i would go to e3 with the biggest smile
if i knew i was going there for two days
exclusivity
you know we see what happened with that
um i just my only concern though i just
hope the esa don't get too greedy and
trying to monetize everything no matter
what i don't want to kick your asa in
the butt yeah you know what i'm saying
but look but i think i i think that's
where read pop comes in because
it's about money obviously it's about
money but you have to know how to do if
you're giving the people what they want
and it's and it's you have to figure out
how people aren't standing online for
hours on end yeah figure stuff out like
that so that the people come in and have
a great experience and they're willing
to spend the money that's the thing give
them a product they're willing to spend
the money on absolutely and last thing i
say is look the reception is positive
i've been seeing it from publishers and
developers since this announcement
people are really taken to it the key
now is what's uh what king said
how does jeff respond because if re-pop
pull this off and e3 is back
he
he or someone gave us a little something
and they stopped being mid yeah you go
for competition forces essa excellence
oh yeah so you know he's gonna have to
step up to the plate he's gonna have to
call kojima in they're gonna have to
have the games on deck
you know cause this year was a little
mid yeah
at that point i think jeff
that's the thing i don't know he at that
point he may have to pivot to just a
virtual thing because he's talking about
in person and that's where he did and we
talked about in person yeah well if you
give me two days i'll be there in person
yo jonathan b say y'all be acting real
different since skull and bones drive
that's
right getting bows outside see you
on 11 008 yo
let's let's combine because we're gonna
let's combine the um gamescom topic with
this this is okay yeah fine yeah then we
do some chat look this month is really
quick um yeah like i was shocked uh xbox
announces they made the statement that
they are going to be
at gamescom you know i mean they're
gonna have a presence let's get that
article up right quick so yeah they said
the show is gonna focus on the next 12
months and it's kind of mirroring the
message from june's xbox it does the
game showcase uh shout out to polygon
which concentrated on gameplay footage
and concrete information on games coming
to 2022 rather than split uh early 2023
rather than splash reveals a far off
games and they talked about um they're
likely to be part of the jeff keithley
hosted opening night live games uh live
stream at gamescom and they said it uh
comes as a relief to uh event organizers
at gamescom because they said sony
nintendo activision blizzard and take
two have all said they will not attend
this year so as of now it looks like um
microsoft ubisoft
bandai namco are the major publishers so
far to say they are coming together what
do we feel about this am i going attic
you anybody
it's gamescom like i'm hoping we get
some good content
i haven't really like it's not that i
don't look forward to gamescom i still
like gamescom i just got
i don't know maybe since the pandemic
hit i gotta like get to this mental
point where i feel like the world's
slowly returning and like i always be on
the oppression all that's going to get
canceled in a couple days
what you feel about them having a
gamescom presence exciting i mean i
think it could be you know obviously
it's they already set it up front like
they should have done for e3 hey next 12
months but the thing is by the time
gamestop gamescom rolls around it's
going to be more than two months since
they had in june we're implying that the
12 months gets extended with
it could be extended we could see
there's something that you know
something new right they they kind of
said
okay
yeah yeah i mean i i could see them
ending on a banger like something that
they didn't show in the gym
again because the 12 months has now
moved two months over right so you know
something that might launch whatever it
at another point in 2023 they could be
like hey uh yeah you know like one more
thing and this is you know give a little
nice little mic drop
the record sir are you in favor of the
12-month format i never got to answer
them
[Music]
i understand the fact that two of their
big games need to be the two big games
got pushed i get it
they needed to do it it was the right
thing to do ultimately
i think they should have let us know
beforehand okay as they've done with
this all right so now that they did
what about 12 bucks moving forward for
every show
for every show
hey guys this is we're showing you 12
months if
if
if we if they start hitting the cadence
with these first party releases that we
think they're going to hit right every
quarter
then that that's that looks pretty good
if you talk about every quarter then
you're looking at three bangers that
you're gonna show me three or maybe four
bangers you're gonna show me in a 12
month span right so
yeah if they start hanging hitting the
cadence with releases with these bangers
that we expect from these first party
studios then 12 months ain't so bad
right
and for me like i said like i i like to
be surprised with something i haven't
seen or heard from before 100
but there's there's always so much bs
attached to it and they're showing cg
they're showing this
end of the day like if you were showing
me concrete
just warn us gamepl what it's gonna be
and again but but this is the thing
right now going back to the e3 thing
right
if e3 as a public event as a huge event
where everybody industry comes together
comes back together the way we hope it
does
then at that point all of a sudden now
we have to go back and start saying hey
this is a big investment we need to give
people something to really get riled up
okay
so
if if things stay small then e3 sort of
flounders when it comes back and it's
not what it was once before and we start
seeing more of these xbox sort of uh you
know smaller shows or whatever
sure the 12-month form is fine if we
have a grand stage where everybody in
the video game industry is focused on
this one thing and it's a it's a big
deal like it was once before then yeah
i'd like to see some mic drop moments of
stuff that i haven't heard about 100
percent that would be my hope and
expectation
king what do you feel xcom i mean xcom
xbox is going to be at gamescom in 2022
and uh the 12 month format returns
well they got stuff to show uh sonny's
not gonna be there because god of war
ain't gonna be there either
ain't got nothing to show
how you got the biggest game of yo of
the year for your franchise and you
ain't at the show for for that for your
market for that market where you're so
strong in that game that you wanted to
to actually do well
uh it's not there still no state of play
so
um state of delay maybe anyway i know
who is going to be there the peoples
they're going to be there you know what
they're going to show 12 months of fun
12 months of fun and you know what
they're going to have and i think salve
is on to something they didn't say 10
months
by the time the show is there it's going
to be 12.
so they might slide out the back door
with the
take that to the gut 12 months just for
you
um
i love microsoft being out there i love
the fact that they are truly transparent
they're trying to be the best that they
can be yeah and a lot of times when you
are transparent you are reactionary um
but i would rather have a juggernaut
that is is sensitive to the words of the
public
than to have a juggernaut that is
indifferent to your cries so again
y'all got a date because y'all flooded
people's emails with uh
nasty stuff um these dudes
gave y'all
times and a time span
out of listening to your cries so again
yeah gamescom because microsoft
understands they can't afford to miss
these big gaming events that actually
showcase what they're in business for
right they're in business to sell games
they're in business to sell you consoles
they're in business to sell you their
services so how the hell you're gonna
have a gamescom without one of the
biggest players makes absolutely no
sense to me it only makes logical sense
that microsoft will be there and give
you a roadmap for what's going forward
because they feel like they're gonna be
there later
i don't know um i'm they're not taking
you for granted i just knew they was
gonna be there anyway and i think the
solve just gave me a light bulb over my
head with that that's why i love him
that's why you know he was sorely missed
when he was on vacation
um because he brings these
little insights that sometimes we might
overlook
um everybody has a supreme voice and is
very needed that's why i love when the
four of us
back up um it's some craziness that's we
turned that e3 time into a movie
that's crazy
yeah i jump in this this is quick um
i i'm still on the record for not being
sold on the 12-month format
um i'm with you king i love them there i
love them there i love that they're
going to have a presence um
i guess it's just what's off said it's
like
there's always a part of me with the
12-month it's like okay this is what
you're gonna get and there's no hope
there's no one there there's no
you don't say anything outside of that i
hope that two months get extended you
know and that is something else you know
but probably nothing i'm not gonna get
too crazy i think maybe we get some more
red fall maybe starfield but you know a
little nugget here and then um
i would like to use the opportunity to
make some game pass announcements of new
games in the service and i don't know if
i said this publicly you know um
focus home you know got some stuff i'm
gonna hit up evil wes see what's going
on over there yeah
you know that has hashtag just one
energy and we played that we got that
on iop they might they might change the
format and how they release the stuff on
their own show right and actually raise
the bar and get rid of the lulls in the
middle they might use that first show as
a test run because remember they want to
actually
win out there in europe yeah where
they're falling behind that and the fact
that the competition doesn't care
because they feel like they have it in
the bag already gives you the
opportunity to put your best foot
forward to actually woo some of the
people that aren't on the platform yet
yeah i would like some game passing
downs i think i think we should see
fawzi that strong fours are strong in
europe yeah motors aboard the game look
phenomenal i think it would be a mistake
not to even though i'm not a monster
like to capitalize on that you got to
show out with motorsports so yeah that's
pretty much all i got on this but um
yeah anything else before we move on to
super chats and last topic all right we
good so i'm going to kill him up
that that's it that was the last topic
right no
no we did technically yeah you put it
you put it together
with the movies you're doing that are
you out oh the movies are sony joy why
not
he's like yeah we're doing that we're
doing it like
so you see
this this is the topic
yeah
all right i'm taking the jury off yeah
yeah so all this was brought to me by
king no i wasn't aware of this um yeah
shout out to pc gamer we're never aware
of how we're [ __ ] yes you know what's
funny
they attacked us there's always
something playstation negative
i don't this is king's topic
they attack us the thing is though is
it's sony that gives uh him the ammo so
blame sony
thank you but i just will be clearing
have their own picks on top every lord
has their own this is king's pick so do
not associate that this is what we try
to focus as a group this is how i want
to talk about so anyway playstation to
remove purchase movies from users
accounts in some regions it looks like
the company's license agreement with
distributor studio canal is set to
expire so um it looks like the placing
stores removing access to over 300
movies and tv shows in germany and
austria due to an expiring license
agreement with that studio studio canal
and it's not usually like a standard d
listing and they saw people who brought
those shows their items will be removed
um from their libraries at the end of
august playstation did official website
make a statement because as of august
31st due to our evolving licenses
agreements with content providers you
will no longer be able to view your
previously purchased studio canal
content and it will be removed from your
video library so this is making the
rounds king this is your topic you want
to talk about it what's up um
okay it's being that you sent out this
wonderful letter telling everybody that
uh my collection of the matrix is gone
i have this wonderful collection of the
matrix and i watch it every saturday
every saturday i go and i turn my music
up and i see keanu reeves and his
brilliance and i love to watch all of it
i especially love roy jones part in the
matrix too and i can get to go to god
about that
and i purchased this
gutenta
is gone
where's my money and why is this
horrible thing happening to me and why
isn't nobody else screaming about that
this is the digital life that people
were totally afraid of because nobody
goes inside your house unless it's a
thief
and steals out your content
you know this is this is this is
thievery and then they're telling you
ahead of time um
tuesday august the 3rd
uh
what you have previously gave full money
for will no longer be in your possession
you no longer own the license you no
longer have the ability to view the
content that you've purchased out of
your hard-earned dollar and we're giving
you no compensation for said thing we're
just giving you a heads up so when you
go to try to
launch it and you get the error code oh
that's not an error
you just bet on the wrong horse
um my question is how come people aren't
screaming this right
i won't agree i didn't see anyone talk
about it for the most part yeah i'll
shut the case out they say hey it's fine
if you want to remove the movies but can
we get a refund of the purchase price
thank you what whatever so addict son
what's your feeling on this man
he's right
at the end of the day i do feel like
they should have some accountability to
what's going on here and i do understand
where he's coming from or it doesn't
seem like they have accountability like
no one's talking about it right i don't
think i've seen one video really about
this and this is big this is a big thing
big issue so it's kind of kind of
curious what's what's happening here so
for clarity solvers
it's a
whole digital storefront of this studio
canal correct studio canal yeah and but
it's only it's affecting austria austria
and germany so it's great okay it's not
ma'am
so uh
yeah are you done at it no
okay yeah
okay yeah um yeah man i mean this this
is again
it's easy to keep it at arm's length
because it's not affecting us directly
right now
but
this is this is the fear it's always
been the fear and as somebody who made
the decision like i'm look i'm not
taking none of this with me uh i'm gonna
go old digital because i don't want to
have all these boxes and stuff around
this is the fear that in your lifetime
the things that you have purchased
licenses to or whatever the case may be
disappear in a way that you can't access
them before you die
and that is that's not cool
and that and and
this is the fear and what's scary about
this is that it's it's it's it's based
it's on a zoning platform right
you would think the movie guys the tv
guys the playstation guys would this is
something you would keep going right you
could see it happening with some other
company that's not their their primary
business
but to see this happening on the sony
side it's yeah you don't want to see
that you don't want to see that because
it's it's it's them showing you like hey
this is you borrowed this
and we could take it away from you
whenever and it doesn't matter that it
looks bad that
you're not going to be asked to be able
to access these movies after x amount of
time um it's not a good look it's not a
good look but again that is that's
always been the fear
of going digital that this is going to
happen um
so i don't know man like
more people should be talking about it
because it really should be put out
there that this is unacceptable yeah
yeah this is unacceptable if you want us
to buy into your digital storefronts and
granted sony has always been reluctant
about this they you know
they were the last ones on the driver
chain when it came to hey man the
digital storefront but at the same time
if you look at their sales the vast
majority of their sales are digital now
so they're all in
so
my hope would be that they do the right
thing and
and you keep those storefronts and
availability open as as long as humanly
possible
and
you know maybe this
it means that they're going to
consolidate this into something else and
maybe maybe you get to access it some
other way shape or form but again it's
happened and that nothing has been said
about why it's happening and maybe some
evolving situation because if you don't
say anything it just seems like they're
gone that's it you're not gonna
so
yeah it's it's a scary proposition but
it is what we expected out of a digital
future so yeah no this is scary part
i'll jump in um you know i'm very
curious about how the other movie rental
services on that platform feel about
that
um you know it's an uneasy feeling you
know i'm i am what's crazy is i am team
digital i am the guy that's lazy that
like don't like the boxes and the discs
and all that other stuff but this is
concerning this is concerning consumer i
think this is even bigger than sony like
consumer protections need to be in place
as to why if you own a whole library
i've owned all these movies and then
this one particular i bought it from
this one service and then they're like
oh we're going out that's it we're
pulling your content and
now everything you know your collection
is gone after a certain date without any
type of protections without that that's
crazy and to me we got to be careful
because the other thing i'm saying i
know if y'all saw that ubisoft joint
with um assassin creed multiplayer games
cause acid creams plc's shut down
servers we're making it so that the new
stuff could be more better
and but what if i love that old
multiplayer i can't never play it again
right what if i go into games as a
service and this is not financially
viable
the multiplayer is fine right i mean
that's their prerogative to shut down
multiplayer the thing is that you the
things that you've purchased that are
associated with that game that should be
available to you in perpetuity exactly
are
they're gone that and dlc
you paid for dlc that why is that going
and
why i got no missing character exactly i
remember when mother marvel ultimate
alliance had dropped the hope
and all these other guys on dlc
luckily if you purchase the dlc at that
time you still get to keep it but
anybody knew they won't be able to get
any of those characters and those are
like huge characters so yeah that this
stuff don't sit well with me and again
i've been team digital i've always been
riding for a digital future but that
stuff
we do i i'm glad king brought up because
we have to put a light on this this is
something we have to pay attention
everybody's quiet
this happens in silence and then the
powers that be look over and say oh
nobody right it nobody screamed nobody
yelled yeah i agree all right pull up
the rest of these got it got to talk
about this stuff and we got to hold
their feet to the fire because if a
storefront goes out you lose everything
and this is where the argument for
physical is strong i'm just happy with
sony
because i'm gonna tell you right now if
this was microsoft the twitter would be
on fire yeah that's kind of true that's
kind of true
yes i'm implying that they turn a blind
eye when when a favorite little kid
decides to throw a cat out the window so
when the when the other little kid just
break a glass
i hate you you don't did so much bad you
you're not good you're never gonna be
good so but sony sony can do so much
harm
absolutely hot and this is harmful i'm
telling you right now somebody has a
whole library of some movies i don't
care if it's let's say it's the fast and
the furious
whole set
the whole set yeah i brought the whole
set every time it came out i paid full
boat on it 49
and every time it came out as soon as it
was able to be there yeah they don't
even get their money back and that's why
that's why the p and you know the people
that that argue against subscription
services whether it be on the
playstation side of the xbox side
the subscription mitigates these issues
in that you don't own nothing
so if they take it away
you know you never owned it you know so
should something happen it's out of
their control that something has to go
away we've seen that with licensed stuff
then it has to go away because they're
not willing to put the money back in to
keep it on the market right uh you know
so it's
it's an evolving situation that is going
to continue to evolve the thing is that
steps have to be taken like cargo saying
to the protections for the consumer have
to be sort of grinding to stone and and
law up front now
and almost honestly we had to pay
everybody back right yep
this is what happened if they had lead
yeah and on a studio level if you bought
it from the studio and you chose to buy
it in that format now that format or
service goes away you don't have access
to that content like
it's so it's weird to be like i don't
know i don't know how they resolve it
but it's like i was probably like well
maybe you know you you get
the digital downloadable like what is it
the uh mp4 whatever it is yeah and then
you can could have ever did i know the
piracy but this is why dudes be wanting
to pirate because they'd be like no you
don't know when you're gonna turn the
lights off and we like i'm not
justifying it i'm just saying like this
is they they're gonna this is they got
to be very careful this could get ugly
quick if they're right it doesn't look
like it's gonna get ugly though
you know what it is it gotta be
something that affect home that more
people love and then you know what i'm
saying there's got to be xbox
[Laughter]
we'll see but that's all i got but good
topic about king um
let me get the poland and you click keep
the chats also yep all right cool new
ilp
poll finally returning after a couple of
weeks with the latest news regarding
halo infinite's lower engagement numbers
on steam as a free to play title what do
you think is the quickest way to get
halo infinite back on track the choices
are a major internal shake up at 343 to
help produce halo infinite content and
fix bugs in a timely fashion for the
live service model
b
remove 343 completely from ownership of
the halo franchise it's time for a fresh
start with another xbox game studios or
c i don't care they need to keep
monetizing halo master chief collection
and that's where the majority of the
halo community is playing anyway to
everybody who's in the chat salute to
everybody that pulled up the lords
returned reunited with the bros it felt
good it's long overdue missed y'all this
was fun as hell
foolishness all four of us you know how
we do
but just get these super chats
uh let me see we got shrimp kingdom two
dollar super chat i'm sorry king phil is
on this three four three under control
damn
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
did y'all check that snoop dogg eminem
track though oh i hear y'all i haven't
heard it yet i heard the video is very
uh doing a lot of powerful stuff
yeah yeah
they got a comedy special too oh wow
that's on netflix that is hilarious kat
williams ashley larry uh
camacho's it it's it's really good
mm-hmm
we got slow-mo back slap never for 25
months
it's really not so much as e3 needs to
be to be back but people want their
showcase wrapped up in three days and
not three months
yeah it's a consolidation like no yeah
across the whole summer just doesn't
it's not the same
yes sir and then we've gotten
it out just problem was he wanted it to
be
you know a long drawn-out event where
every day you're celebrating for months
ain't nobody got time for that we got
work we got we gotta get stuff to do
on twitch my homie audible up there he
did the that's the guy responsible for
the beat on iop he's on twitch right now
watching the salute i had to shoot about
all right there's no doubt
uh let me see tyson but joe eight dollar
super chat in 2019 everyone was saying
e3 is dead and what's death upon it for
three years we have suffered
more than a halo infinite content
creator hashtag watch your mouth
yeah yeah
we got a ceo
[Laughter]
i doubt they have days for just media i
doubt they'd have days just for media
they could do mornings for media and
then bring in general public later in
the day general attendees need to have a
reason to be there as well
why do i need to be there the whole week
though
look at this this is this impression
like i mean pax is what pax is wednesday
thursday friday you really have the
other weekend as well
i don't understand like it just arrives
or arrive when it's time for you to
arrive
i remember that's why i'm not trying to
go back
but don't let nobody else keep whatever
that's right
no i mean look
it's like i said like i don't think
anyone's like validating like people
shouldn't get an opportunity to do that
i think it's like
if if you if you're about this grinding
stuff then you know that's that's the
end game and
i think there's a difference between
letting people in an event and letting
people overshadow the people that's
doing it like if you're going there for
like content creator-wise that's
different than going there it's just a
casual consumer in the gaming industry
and then you're in line with someone
that's doing it for a living you know
what i'm saying
don't touch me
jesus
i don't want to be here then get out
i was ready to say that like four times
doing this line get out time what kid
get his elitism
hold on i had to mute for a second
because apparently the bronx is wilding
out today
yes there's some things going on um
exactly
[Laughter]
jd gave her a ten dollars
imagine this
read pop's e3 expanded to a 10-day event
with the first three days press only and
three days worth of digital content
follow-ups and fans get four days of
dedicated read pop style community fan
service that's uh that's a lot of
content that's a lot
hey tom
hey you pre-ordered that right now
i'm starting trouble he's a smart man
absolutely he still has his
good to see eyebrows
[Laughter]
oh my bad audible i thought she was the
other guy my father yeah you didn't make
the beat that's right wasn't true but
salute to you salute to you thank you
for being honest i ain't made no beats
cause i would have said a bunch of
people his way
[Laughter]
i gave him a whole new clientele for no
reason my fault people just started
calling him i ain't no you got beat
[ __ ]
you hiding them beasts
and laughs about
imagine like the person's ass like i
don't do that
or why are you doing it for iop
oh so now now you're going to now you
know
yeah
[Laughter]
how does it feel
to know that you could have potentially
just ended friendship yeah my fault i
messed up a messed up
dude that's daniel wilkins
yeah you sent him the audible and then
the order was twitter pages religious
things yeah you know what carl
you got religious beasts
i got one thing to say to you man he's a
10. but he mistakes people in the chat
for other people there you go that's me
that's me
all right we got uh let me see dee dee
lee shout out to dd leave for 24 months
king wants his exclusive club to stay
exclusive to gamers
no no i just want to do i want to have
more time to actually work that's one
thing
we gotta wear my crocs in peace
they need to not give us a name
all right all right
we need
we got appgam 72 member for 18 months
absolutely this is how they do it at
gamescom and tokyo game show first two
days of media only and the rest of the
week is open to the public i read this
already but i felt that it required the
second reason
for being in control my man
you got tyson joe three dollar super
chat king phil would be disappointed in
you that's a lie he loves everything i
just said i mean does does phil wait in
line for anything not uh
so now we're getting compared with the
the person who controls all of exo okay
he brought phil into this door
keep my ceo name out
[Music]
they're going to put king's mouth oh
yeah they definitely did somebody go i
didn't cut it up
you already know how they do let's see
that within the hour thank you keep my
ceo's name
out yo
savage
then we got a little pixel bit team
member for 31 months thank you so much
appreciate that
i'm happy to support the iron czars
podcast even if i'm a lowly pleaser
thank you very lucky to associate with
us thank you come back then like we
won't come outside and shake your hand
not not in two days
people i got to get that go to your
player yeah you know who down with me
right
all the lords of gamer.net
[Laughter]
17 two pound super chat king forgot that
he was on that mall floor clutching race
yeah but that don't got nothing to do
with two days like why not
that has nothing y'all talk about fan
fest i'm not talking about that i'm
talking about actually two days to
actual work i want to work
i want to work without worrying about
barbra jean talking about i'm tired of
you playing video games jim
i don't know
we got donation chat ever since the
lord's got media credentials they've
done chains on the ninjas
also
we are the ones in the scrum downstairs
see cog is talking from uh uh ivory
tower he's up there eating caviar
we're down in the pulpits
[Music]
let's ask to go sit in the lines and
stuff again i know right you know he
who was that he was with platinum games
right yo they took him to a whole
different
home
oh where was being is
[Music]
[Music]
then we got splendiferous two dollars of
a chat what happened to me casa sukasa
only if you media that's that's correct
remind them of their roots before they
was media your flight comes in at
tuesday night or wednesday morning
[Laughter]
then we got the wise old game remember
for 23 months
you know who else thought he only needed
two days
oh my god
how'd that work out for
time on that moving on
we got ksit five dollar super chat man i
think i can represent the whole chat
when i say we missed y'all no more iop
days off hashtag plebes need love too
oh my god
salute
then we got slobo backslap five dollars
in the chat
this is a quote
give the rabble access on wednesdays i
don't want that filth touching me today
[Music]
[Applause]
another taco two thousand chat sony and
sony fanboys stay giving us ammo weekly
yep
i just wait i i say i start off the week
we're having nothing by thursday i'd be
like damn i don't got no topic
god said hey sony just did this
good looking god okay you sign it all
the time
then we got flame two dollars for chat
all aboard the ss high seas all aboard
the bougie lords the boozy lords all
right hold on we got dj oros five dollar
super chat hashtag leg day hashtag
bestie hashtag not invited to e3
you invited with me you're vibe with me
dj divided with me if you are working on
those free two days that we're fighting
for you for mm-hmm
i got it you could do the good work for
the people he's gonna take you to the
ivory tower he's gonna bypass he get two
days anyway oh stop here we go
then we got stitch remember
do you all think that sony will be
giving a free up we will be giving free
upgrades to god of war when the game's
released next year when the game
releases next year wow on the ps4 and
eventually ps5 they already said no more
free upgrades
they said that so they horizon was the
last time they said they're going to
support the the playstation 4 for five
years but you're gonna support them for
life
you know it's kind of crazy the fact
that kev said after this when we're done
give a chance
i gotta respect that one
dj said he gotta make aurosgaming.net
just to go
there you go you going anywhere you
gonna be there stop playing around i saw
pictures of you at another show
we got documentation
the mainly people that are like king's
talking about is just like the people
that are just consumers going to the
shows not talking about content creators
like people don't want to buy socks oh
my god you know those dudes they got a
whole soccer line i got the new naruto
socks
did you go get the button they're giving
free buttons out over there how dare
they want to come to show interest in
the games industry yeah they pay to come
yeah yeah yeah for three days
when the doors open for you
yeah
it's like me being in front of madison
square garden demanding they let me in
before the nick game starts
i got cog again bad faith they have two
different lines for media and for public
if they told us we had to all get on
that public line
you have your one day sir
[ __ ] would not go this is unacceptable i
got to go in there i got to work why the
hell i got a 10 o'clock appointment
remember that i got to 10 o'clock i got
my way
moving on
and we got lord metro two dollars super
chat king saab won an amendment for the
two-day press yes amendments
need to be made thank you very much put
it on my badge let's put it change.org
it'll be there
and then we're caught up so far here we
go
all right let's get out of there
now lord addict we can find people first
what you got going on sir
follow me uh lord addict iop on twitter
uh you can also find me uh on the attic
show this wednesday at 5 00 pm with uh
hustle motivate maybe uh
i don't know i don't want to announce
people that might not come on some
developers on recently i mean dart
griggity might be uh there dirk grady's
like my uh rotating wheel
chain third chair yeah yeah rotating i
don't care
he might be on there i did uh just have
obsidian uh on uh
uh appreciate everyone foreign
it was is megan sharks uh she's the lead
uh the lead writer one of the senior
writers
he's talking about how to get in the
game industry right
now
clearly you didn't watch it that wasn't
it it's not about narrative writing in
the industry talk about your damn show
let's go
but you also did phantom brigade right
mm-hmm yeah that's what i'm trying to
try to talk about what i just did and i
don't know what i'm just doing
so we also interviewed uh fan brigade uh
you know it was pretty
pretty good interview you could check
that on the uh on the on the channel
that you're currently watching this on
we went over you know what it was like
to make that kind of game uh you know a
lot of people don't make strategy games
these days so i do like to highlight the
ones that do
um this wednesday obviously we'll be
back five people i want to thank the
people that came out to the to the
sunday show last week you know we uh had
a pretty big show last week it was me
kiss move uh dirt griggity and uh hustle
yeah that's why hustle was in the chat
saying because the the chat spirit
bought him straight to the shadow round
uh so he i'm sure he's going to be back
wednesday with vengeance
because of what was said on this show
but i appreciate ever coming through i
definitely tune in wednesday at 5 00 pm
uh you know hopefully if i if i can i
get king on uh but you know he's pretty
busy but you know uh i will be
restructuring certain things on the
on iop uh just bear with me give me some
more time we are
in the process of getting some more
merchandise out for you i don't know if
king has an update on that
oh yeah yeah working on it okay
okay we're working on it that's the
update uh we add up to like i think
almost 750 people in here at once yes uh
so that that was nice you guys showed up
every week especially after we missed we
usually we get like a dip and viewership
when we miss a week
we don't miss very long that's why when
carl uh saul was like we're gonna be out
this week so we we didn't have show i
was like i'm gonna i'm gonna schedule
attic show that week i appreciate you
guys holding it there
a lot of people uh showed up hopefully
some of you will come over to this
wednesday at 5 00 p.m and i will see you
later man we got we got a lot of good
stuff scheduled for you guys i know you
some of you have messaged me asking me
about the community event thing uh i get
it it's been months of saying it but we
we got four people we got to work around
schedules you know
talk to someone about dropping the back
so we just do this full time and then we
can do whatever you want
give me a reason to stay home please
some people ask me about my shirt my
shirt is a my hero's shirt
so i appreciate everyone coming i got my
hair on too
my
hero yeah that's all no doubt a little
soft back off that two-week vacation
yeah chilling you you can catch me
playing on my steam deck and being able
to actually play my triple play game my
triple a games
that's it or back to work obviously
because god forbid like you know
back at it that's why you got to
subscribe to the podcast hit the like
subscribe
could be here all day exactly talking to
y'all playing games no doubt lord king
looking to find people find you what you
got going on sir well
everything is working out i'm working
hard
uh trying to get the second studio up
and running i mean it's a whole visual
thing and there's a whole other stuff
that i'm working on and be honest with
you like uh you know
what i'm saying that mine are looking
crispy
people you know um
people have jobs so and lives and
there's a whole bunch of stuff moving
parts going on especially when you got
kids and stuff like that
but
uh this saturday
uh we should have a combat talk with the
king a graphic guard just updated a
whole bunch of stuff looks fantastic
love exactly where everything is going
and what we're trying to uh introduce uh
to you guys so
i'm gonna have this stuff we're gonna be
rolling it out to you and then kos is
also coming as well as far as the merch
goes merch is gonna get updated you're
going to get some stuff that y'all were
looking for you're going to get some
surprise stuff um attic and i talked
about some stuff and me and i'm going to
talk very
uh intensely uh coming up because we
really got all the stuff that the
podcast needed out of the way
so it's a private project it's a passion
project the addict uh was talking about
that he wants done so um i'm definitely
there to work with him and get this
stuff done and get it out so
a lot of content as far as merch is
coming your way and attic anytime you
need me on your show you know i'm there
um
so that's combat talk with the king
saturdays at 10 p.m
and uh soon kos is gonna be up but
one show at a time
getting that stuff out and i truly miss
sovereign uh
the periods that he wasn't here every
time he's not here i miss him uh because
it's little nuggets and stuff like that
that i get to bounce off each and every
last one of these guys here
have a totally different opinion on how
i see things and and how they view
things than me
so i get a chance to really have sound
boards that i appreciate because i
appreciate cogs opinion on something i
really appreciate addict's opinion and
the way that sovereign actually dissects
the thing i really don't see sometimes
how he sees it that's the reason why
this man predicted activision because he
thinks outside of the box and nobody
predicted activision but him yeah i
agree man it's when we all fall together
it's it's it's it's something right
that's what the whole the back
i challenge people to debate how much
fun we have
yeah same thing good to be back good to
see everybody back good to recharge your
battery a little bit chat fantastic um
yeah we got stuff coming with some big
surprises we cook it up um talk to king
talk to to addict we got some really
things some guests coming as well so be
on the lookout and um some
content
exclusive as well as some show stuff as
well so be a lookout for that but yeah
that's all i got man everybody enjoy
your sunday and we are out of here let
me see if anything then hold on no we
just got uh shout out to rayne g4
remember for 25 months put a bunch of
crush in the chat thank you brother
that's it we're good
everybody
peace
[Music]
so
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
oh